it being 10 o'clock we'll start the work
session on House Bill 50.
so do I have anybody out there that
would like to uh comment uh Mike or
foreign
if you want to take a seat and use your
mic I was reminded by former chair
umberger that none of us used our mics
at the last uh discussion we had nobody
could hear us so please use your mics
will be great thanks uh thank you Mr
chairman uh for the record Marty Carlin
representing the New Hampshire
retirement system
um
hb50 is um fairly straightforward and
something this Committee in both members
of the House incentive seen in Prior
years uh the spillwood
um as written uh have the state pay
seven and a half percent of the local
employer contribution
costs for uh its employ for their
teachers police and fire members to nhrs
so From nhrs's perspective this this
bill has no impact on either the
unfunded liability or the amount of
funds we receive in a given year out of
employer contributions it just simply
comes out of a different pocket
um one question that um one of the
members on finance asked is
is there any way actually to project if
this bill were to pass you know what
salaries would salaries increase for
um different employers and that that's
there are too many variables in that
question to for the naturitis accurately
perform we do have what's called a
payroll growth assumption and we would
assume in a vacuum that you know
um you know the payroll would grow at a
steady Pace every year we know that's
not the case but for police and fire
it's 2.75
2.25 for teachers so whatever the amount
on the fiscal note
um you know for for next year
um that was put in that's basically
previously contributed amounts from
fiscal 21 rolled forward at that
Inc that those rates have increased and
that that's how we would see the bill
playing out obviously
um salaries are going to differ between
communities raises are going to be
different
um that's a percent of covered payroll
so if um employers were to add staff
that's going to increase payroll uh
things like that so there's too many
variables to predict what impact on
local spending this subsidy would have
this is something that had been in
effect since 1977 through fiscal uh
2011.
uh
and uh I think that's basically you know
my questions that I wanted to address
that my colleagues last week didn't have
at their fingertips
Marty could you spell your last name for
the clerk oh sure k-a-r
-l-o and as in Nancy
just a little heads up for those of you
that have never been on a Division
before
what we'll do is we'll take we can take
testimony or if you have questions of
someone that may be sitting here you're
free to ask them what we'll do at the
end we can hold on to the bill
we can pass the bill we can itl the bill
what we'll do is be making a
recommendation to the full committee
whoever makes that motion has to write
the committee report for the committee
so if you're making a motion be prepared
to write the committee report
representative McGuire I know you have
questions on this bill
you know me too well
thank you Mr Carlin for coming
um
so
this is maybe not so much on the bills
per se but on what you just said all
right so you just said that your
assumptions are that salaries are going
to go up by two point something percent
right
um but I believe that this committee is
as a whole is contemplating state
salaries going up more like five percent
per year for the next two years uh for
this biennium and so
so it seems to me you're really
underestimating
um are those things are those things
that you just said likely to change soon
we we
um when we talk about our assumptions
including salary growth those those are
reviewed uh and updated as needed in any
actual experience studies which are
conducted every four years uh the next
one that we have is in um
it's it closer fiscal 23 so
um spring of uh 24 is when the board
will be looking at recommendations from
the actuaries and it's not so it's not
nothing we're looking at you know
today's rate of inflation and adjusting
on the Fly uh you know there are
assumptions that um we hope are
reasonable over a longer period
historically
um our payroll growth assumption has
lagged wages over the last decade we
last adjusted I think we kept it at 275
and 225.
no I think it was three percent and two
two and a half uh the uh in the 2019 and
before the 2019 experience study so it's
something
um we we look at but
um you know it we don't expect it every
year that to be a straight line it's you
know over you know 10 or 20 or 30 year
period that it's going to average out to
something in that range
okay yeah I'd like to make a ask a
related question so if salaries are
accelerating faster than you currently
expect does that is that have sort of an
outsized effect on the unfunded
liability because
it because we pay the benefits are
related to the top average of the top
five years right so if we if somebody
gets all of a sudden a big raise that
that affects their top five years so so
it directly affects benefits but on the
other hand it doesn't change what we
have saved at all right we have a
certain amount saved to pay those
benefits right so so it must
have a big effect on unfunded liability
is that correct it's it's sort of a
double-edged sword uh in the sense that
a salaries outpace expectations and
projected benefits are based on average
final salary on a five-year average for
most people who are working right now so
you know that has upward pressure on the
liability however we're also receiving
more in contributions than we expected
in a given year because the payroll is
higher than we expected so that's money
in Money that we're investing now money
that we're paying you putting towards
the unfunded liability so there's a
there's a positive and a negative effect
and a lot of it is depends on
foreign
increases are these rewarding people
closer to retirement are these starting
wages that are increasing there's a
there's a lot of variables to tease out
to see ultimately what the impact is but
there's there's sort of a double-edged
sword with that you know a positive and
a negative
members have a representative Griffin
um this is similar to the bill that we
had last year and I think that the
amount of money involved with something
like 50 million dollars
uh that there was a one-time payment uh
and I believe it was House Bill 1221
last year and that that was an after the
fact reimbursement of a percentage of
fiscal 22 contributions uh I I thought
that ended up being in the 26 27 million
range and
um I think this this fiscal note is a
little bit higher but it gets rolling
forward projecting a larger covered
payroll and if I if I may too I realize
there are probably some newer members
either on finance or new to retirement
issues so I just wanted to double back
and when we talk about employer
contribution rates I just want to make
sure everyone understands our employer
rates are set by the actuary and they're
a percentage of of covered payroll so
for all the pensionable wages that the
employees and other members are earning
the employers are paying a percentage of
that to nhrs the rates are different for
the four member groups employees
teachers police and fire
um so you know there are so it's a
percentage of the total payroll
so that that leads me to a question
um we know now based on uh the last bill
how much money was involved has anyone
analyzed that money to see
if uh if
uh what what the distribution would be
by town
if the state in place of a bill like
this just were to take that 27 million
dollars and give it to the towns across
the board based on population
and I'd I'd like to see the figures that
would would result because I suspect
What's Happening Here
is that the small towns are subsidizing
the large cities
I may be wrong I haven't seen the
figures but that's my my gut feel is
that uh I live in a town that has very
few full-time employees
so the retirement pay what they pay into
the retirement is is probably less per
capita than a big city does
so I'm kind of interested to see those
figures of those available we can we can
pull together and share the um the town
by town and school school districts what
they received under uh HB 1221 last year
again it was a percentage of the total
contribution so certainly mon Vernon got
a lot less the Dash rule but as a
percentage of what you put in it's the
same amount but we can get that we
um because of the way uh wages and
contributions are reported to us and and
some
um you know when we begin to close the
books after the fiscal year
um you know there's some reconciliation
issues with numbers so we I think we
have in town by Town information on all
but for employers that were still
working with them to to True up exactly
what they gave us and to for them to get
their reimbursement from the state we
the money and that to help us build 1221
last year wasn't from nhrs I was a
general fund appropriation and it went
through the treasury uh you know with
the assistance of dra but I can I can
get you that list of what people got
I'll send it to the
full committee or
if there's an email for such a group
thank you I would appreciate that
further questions representative evil
thank you Mr chair
um I am new to the committee meeting so
this is rather a basic question so um
I'm sorry for this for other people but
I I really would like to just go back to
the um the origination story of the
relationship between the towns and the
state and and how this came to pass and
part of my interest is whether the towns
would have entered into this agreement
if the if they'd known that the state
might later renege on it so any you
anything you can help me with I I do
have a a
document that talks about employer
contributions that I can send over to
the committee I'll summarize now but
just just to have because because there
are um you know there's some I've seen
that commentary for many years in many
places and I've never been able to in my
research to to completely prove or
disprove that contention
um you know I I can tell you that when
nhrs was Consolidated from four separate
plans back in the 60s uh originally
there was a 40 reimbursement for Teacher
contributions by local school districts
and that was a carryover from the the
teachers retirement system which was the
predecessor plan and that the state had
been doing that 40 percent as far as I
can see back at least until the early
1950s possibly all along
um we um the discussion and deliberation
of the college consolidation back in 67
aren't available online they may be in
the state archives and I've never had
the 48 hours or so for you to go over
there and bury myself in it because I'm
quite interested in seeing what that
what that was but I've never found a
letter from a retirement system or the
municipal Association or the state or
news clipping or anything that
specifically said this was a promise or
this wasn't so I can't give you a
definitive answer on that I I do know
that in 1977 that 40 percent change uh
the 40 State contribution was extended
was reduced to 35 percent for schools
but extended to group two police and
fire and that those amounts were paid
through
um 2009 so 32 years in the legislature
at that time reduced it on a provisional
basis for two years to go up to 30
percent and 10 25 and 11 and back when
it was changed in 09 it was going to
snap back to 35
obviously the state's Financial picture
change considerably was already under
the Great Recession in 09 but it
continued so uh the at 11 the
legislature repealed that as a
combination of the changes to the
pension benefits that reduce costs for
employers plus a a three and a half uh
percent approach three and a half
million appropriation from the state
in the fiscal 1213 employer rates it
they were paying what they would have
been paying you know had the 35 percent
gone in and the plan not changed so
those two years but then sort of the
sticker shock hit the towns uh in the
1415 rates so they then they're out of
pocket dollars went a lot higher at that
point so you know there's a lot of
pieces but that sort of origin story
I've never been able to get
to the bottom of
further question
representative evil
representative cambrell should I say say
that correctly Campbell yeah
I representative McGuire then yeah I
wanted to follow up or ask
representative Evil's question in a
slightly different way
aren't municipalities and school
districts political subdivisions of the
state and therefore to what extent do
they have choice in in being part of the
retirement system
um for for and this this again dates
back to the predecessor plans as well
but uh if you if you employ full-time
teachers police or fire fighters those
positions of mandatory enrollment in the
retirement system so a town has no say
you know if you're gonna you're a small
town you want to hire a couple
full-timers on the fire department
whatever those people are active
contributing members you know in group
two
um you know the their some statutory
exceptions to mandatory membership for
things like you know fixed term
appointments but generally speaking uh
you know those positions are all in
um and for
um
the state uh participation in the
retirement system is mandatory for State
of New Hampshire employees communities
May opt to enter the retirement system
for their full-time employees capital E
you know your town hall folks your DPW
folks things like that that was also a
component of what was then called the
state employees retirement system back
you know towns could do that back in the
40s and 50s as well so
um you know over the course of time you
know we still see employers joining even
you know now in our our we always say we
have about 460 employers because that
number could change sometimes school
districts bifurcate into two districts
or we pick up a small town up north that
never had anybody before things like
that so so they have to have an
affirmative vote of their governing body
to animation into the retirement system
going forward
so that that's how they how they do it
for their ease Manchester never did for
its employees they had their own plan
um I don't know when that started Nashua
DPW is another
separate retirement system you know
completely outside of us for those
employees in Nashua and some towns may
do
um Define contributions or you know Ira
type setups you know for their plans you
know we don't we don't know who's what
people who aren't in the system do if
anything but that's how it works thank
you
representative Hewitt any questions
so just following along so if I
understand what you are saying there are
certain employees of the political
subdivisions that have to be part of the
retirement system and then
you folks set the amount that has to be
paid into the retirement system for
those employees regardless of who's
making the payment correct
okay thank you
it's clear that you can't retire
apparently I can't get sick either but
um we are coming back in tomorrow
unfortunately because I was Ill last
week we couldn't do it to do a sort of
an orientation bigger picture on the
retirement system how it works for this
committee tomorrow afternoon at three so
it would have been better to have that
before you guys got your hands in the
Hamburg
representative Weiler who's sitting in
to keep an eye on representative Maguire
okay
thank you Mr chairman Mr Carlin
looking at history of the system when we
when it first went everybody together
bringing in the towns as well as the
state employees my impression is
those outside the state employees were a
much smaller group than they are now and
now I believe they're like 70 percent
can you remember any of those figures
I I would have to look and see I I you
know in general terms I believe you're
correct I don't have any specific
numbers to to look back and confirm that
on I could I could try to research and I
know the the plan was much smaller you
know obviously when we started in the
state was a larger employer or full-time
employees I think a lot of towns have
added well both you know things thinking
about you know the 70s I mean even you
know the 70s to the 90s the state's
population grew so much certainly the
teacher population grew considerably and
probably Public Safety followed suit so
you know I I think there's you know I
see your point my point is that you know
that we never imagined there would be
this much growth which we've witnessed
and I've seen a lot of our small towns
they start out with no one no employees
except teachers they don't have they
have on-call fire and on-call police and
then all of a sudden why don't we have
full time and so in my town I'm in 50
some years there in the town I've seen
them go from zero to are now probably 40
or 50 and I think it's a pattern that's
that's repeated all across the state
which I mean we have to be aware of that
when we bring these things in that now
this is the major
part of the retirement system where it
at the Inception it was just a small
piece so I think that's that's
significant
we we do have a slide that we're
bringing along tomorrow but our head
count of active members has been
relatively flat over the last 10 or 15
years
um the the distribution is a little
different we did lose a number of state
employees back in the nine two thousand
nine eleven
um layoffs that that that head counts a
little bit lower and we've also seen a
decrease in the number of active
teachers over time and that that seems
to have rebounded a little in the past
couple years but netover net
um and that that's a sort of an aging of
New Hampshire school aid population
issued more than anything else but we've
seen growth in the numbers on the police
of fire and to some extent local
employees
all right um well you have one more
question yeah I'll well related to what
you just said so I'm 65 and I I'm at the
peak of the baby boom so I'm guessing
that a lot of people are retiring right
now or have in recent years
um is the overall number of current
employees so so what I'm saying is is
hiring in general for all employees in
the system bigger than retirements or at
the moment retirement's bigger than
hiring uh you know the way and if
there's somebody behind me by now from
nhma maybe they could speak to that with
more Authority than I can I when we are
doing our head counts and things like
that they're always point in time as of
June 30th so that's active members as of
and retired members you know as of
things like that and and as I said the
active head count has been staying
relatively flat I think it went up a
couple hundred but you know that that
when you're talking about
close to 49 000 members that's a small
uh variation year over year in the past
two years we have seen a higher number
of retirements than we've had in the
prior you know three to four years
behind that I think you know there was a
lot of
um you know with covid you know there's
a lot of speculation on what teacher is
going to bail and this and that and
actually what we've seen is more a
higher percentage on the public safety
side particular police moving out there
may be a host of factors involved in
that you know beyond demographics
um but we wouldn't speculate because
because we don't know that you know
exactly what what's driving an
individual's choice
foreign
ER
well we are we have to put together a
balanced budget we rely on the ways and
means to give us a projection for
roughly 27 months from the time we
finish this
and they've been pretty accurate
sometimes two percent or less
and
all the other things that are we doing
the budget we say this is all you can
spend
this is an uncontrollable figure
as we've pointed out the small towns
keep adding people
there's a lot of pressure to give huge
increases in pay because of all the
inflation
those are things we have totally no
control over so for 27 months we have no
idea what's 27 percent of what
we have no clue
it could double
and that all of a sudden would unbalance
this budget and we'd have no control
they'd come back to us and say you
screwed up I don't want to hear that I
want to be able to say we presented a
budget it came out within a couple of
percent of what we thought it would be
we couldn't do that if we if we pass
this Bill thank you
so Marty we'll be seeing you tomorrow at
three o'clock maybe you can answer some
of the questions that representative
Ebel had put forward as far as the
history sounds like that would be a good
time to get that in there
um Miss heck uh those questions that
um representative Griffin had as far as
if we gave the 26 million dollars to the
towns versus this annual contribution
towards the retirement system maybe you
could put those numbers together for us
and oh you already have those
I'm not
step forward then
my name is Catherine heck I'm with the
New Hampshire Municipal Association we
represent the 234 cities and towns or
political subdivisions in New Hampshire
so I'm happy to answer some of your
questions I do have a document to your
question representative Griffin that
contains the amounts certified as of
September 30th I know there's an updated
record but this is what I was able to
bring so you can have a look and see how
this was distributed town by Town School
District by school district
anecdotally for example the city of
Rochester received 163 thousand dollars
and the Rochester school district has
received 395 thousand dollars that's for
example the town of Allenstown received
nineteen thousand dollars for an example
and the town of Epsom fifteen thousand
so you're correct that there's it really
is
um dependent on the number of full-time
employees and to representative Weiler's
point and it will vary significantly
town by Town School by school but then
you can get a sense of what the impact
was this this bill in particular when
we're comparing House Bill 1221 last
year's bill which was a one-time payment
that was structured a little bit
differently it was 26.7 million dollars
was the estimate and that was a
reimbursement so towns paid 100 percent
and received a reimbursement based on
this formula they reported it on the
ms-434 the majority there were a few
towns that it wasn't quite reconciled so
therefore reporting it as Revenue
reduced the tax rate
because they didn't get their check till
December so it's not as if they spent
the money the bill that we're looking at
today house bill 50 would reinstate 7.5
percent so it would reduce the cost so
towns would only have to budget 92.5
therefore reducing their budget line
when they're asking for the
appropriation on the front side so they
are a little bit different and the
one-time payment but I do think last
year's one-time payment was very well
received it made a tremendous difference
and I think you can kind of get a sense
of the impact that it had on cities and
towns so I also appreciate some of the
comments about being a little bit of a
moving Target right as we can't predict
salaries or raises that might need to be
put in place to retain employees we
towns are like the state unable to
employ they are still looking and having
the same retention issues and the same
replacement issues that we're seeing in
all Industries all over the state the
country so while we do try one for one
it's not necessarily the case if we
can't find a qualified candidate or no
one's applying for the jobs and of
course in theory
some senior people might leave and a
newer person might a junior person may
take over at what we might assume to be
a lower rate but we can't guarantee that
in today's market so all things to
certainly consider and I can also
appreciate as a finance person you know
again that moving Target that you talk
about so of course if the state capped
the reimbursement of seven and a half
percent or up to a certain dollar amount
that could certainly assist in the
budgeting process because I can
appreciate that you have to bring
forward a balanced budget as a resident
myself of the State of New Hampshire
that's important work as well so I'm
happy to answer other questions that you
might have if I didn't cover things
so to representative Griffin's question
earlier he was I think looking and he
can correct me if I'm wrong but if we
were to distribute say that nearly 27
million dollars to the towns not through
the retirement system but based on say
their population how would that compare
to what they would get under the 7.5
versus a contribution it's like Revenue
sharing that type of thing so so if we
look at meals and rooms that was
distributed at 121 million that would be
maybe really roughly a fifth of that and
that's just strictly population based so
we can certainly I can certainly get a
spreadsheet and do that math for you to
see what that would look like in a
different way solely based on population
using meals and rooms formula if that's
acceptable to you
okay I'm happy to do that for you
further questions representative Weiler
thank you Mr chairman Miss heck we in
this current budget and for the year
2023 are giving back 100 million from
swept
directly to the property taxpayers have
you done an analysis of how much that's
going to each town
so swept is
um so the hundred thousand unswept is
very interesting and they're having 100
million 100 million I'm sorry that's a
very different number yes but who's
counting there's just a few zeros there
I apologize I made the same mistake
myself I'm sorry
um that's very interesting in that
analysis as swept is collected and
retained locally it does not go back up
to the state and then be redistributed
back to the cities and towns so what
some other policy analysts have noticed
so I don't do education funding
particularly although it all interplays
and all interacts so I do follow the
conversation the reduction of swept has
led property poor towns to having to
raise funds locally because the
reduction isn't covering their portion
of the school Bill property wealthy
towns I believe you've seen there was an
injunction because they were retaining
more than what they needed so well
um it's certainly on paper a red
reduction to the taxpayer and I'm sure
all the taxpayers appreciate it if it
has to be flip-flopped and raised on the
local school tax there really was no net
reduction so I don't have the data on
that I do know that there have been some
analysis on how that swept worked now
that we've done it for two years to
further understand the property
valuation and how it impacts the swept
tax
thank you
thank you so what we'll do now since I
try to keep right on schedule
we'll reschedule this work session for a
later date when the questions that
representative Ebel had McGuire and
Griffin our address was hearing from the
retirement system tomorrow again at
three you're welcome to join us miss
heck and uh we'll schedule another work
session after we get those answers
thanks thank you very much
just get one more for the file thanks
so next we have House Bill 555
appropriating state general fund Surplus
towards the retirement system unfunded
liability
anyone like to come forward ah yes the
representative from Hudson
yes I'm uh representative Tony luckis
representing Hillsboro 38 the towns of
Hudson and Litchfield thanks thank you
to the uh
subcommittee um
so the uh
the pension fund has something on the
order of 5 billion in unfunded liability
uh there's someone here from the
retirement system that can probably
provide a more detailed
data on that and there was a
you know there's a history of it being
unfunded there was a some legislative
action that took place around 2010 to
put it on the past to be fully funded
and under statute it's supposed to be by
about 2039
so the way that's the unfunded liability
is currently being paid is all the
employers and in that context it's all
the government entities that have
employees in the pension fund so that's
uh
the state the counties uh cities towns
school districts Etc
they're paying a percentage
of their total payroll the payroll of
their employees that are in the pension
system
towards the unfunded liability so
they're paying two parts the cost to
actually soundly pay for the pensions
for their current employees and then a
portion for paying off the unfunded
liability and to get it done by 2039
again person retirement system can
provide more details but I believe it's
something on average more than 80
percent of what all those government
employers are paying is to pay the
unfunded liability not the current
pension it may be less than that but
um we can get that number and that comes
in most cases directly out of
everybody's property tax
so the idea is that if we have a surplus
and if the uh what's colloquial known as
the rainy day fund is is maxed out
that um a portion of any remaining money
go towards the unfunded liability 75
percent is is what I pick but if the
committee wants a different percentage
I'd be fine with 100 or whatever
um
and you know putting money into that
early is like paying your mortgage off
early because that invested money gets a
return and it will more quickly
um
pay that off and every two years the
pension system calculates the percentage
of the total payroll that goes towards
paying off the unfunded liability and if
the amount oh you know that is not
funded uh goes down then that is going
to go down and as there's return gained
on that money that's invested it'll go
down further as you go
and eventually at the end not only are
the employers can be paying less because
they won't be paying off the unfunded
liability but the way the system is set
up
the employee contribution will actually
go down as well
as that's paid off because right now the
employees are paying over half of the
cost of their pension their employer is
paying a smaller amount and I believe in
statute
the employees can't be higher than the
employer so as the employee part goes
down
the employers would have to I mean the
employee as the employer's particles on
the employees would have to as well so I
mean it's one way to get a at least the
opportunity for a property tax reduction
for everybody assuming the money isn't
just spent by the employer
so that's that's all I have
questions for representative Lucas
thank you
anyone else
representative
Parsons right Pearson
thank you for the record Representative
Steve Pearson him Rockingham District 13
now which is the town of Derry I'm a
co-sponsor of this legislation
um just to just to add a little bit to
what the representative from Hudson said
when the when all 50 states took a deep
dive when when the alarm was sounded
back in around 07.
there were 50 different concepts 50
different ideas right every state looked
at their situation and said okay we all
got to do something so
and they all came up with different
ideas
and you know as we look forward 15 years
later
we see that there were states that were
serious and then there were states that
were maybe serious for a year
New Hampshire
after
the decennial commission and and the
real hard look at what was going on
there
put into place a plan that was serious
but in the grand scheme of things
looking at some other states not
necessarily as quick we decided to do
over a 30-year run some states were much
more aggressive
and I think that you know when you have
an opportunity to pay your bills
you put you should do so that that's a
that's something that people in their
personal finances do it's something
certainly that the state should be doing
as well so
I think this this kind of shifts the
gear a little bit it moves us up into a
little bit more of an aggressive stance
to do this and especially now in a down
Market
infusing that system with any sort of
money certainly has a multiplier effect
as the market Rises so
you know I fully support this concept I
think that it's something maybe we
should have been you know really brought
into play years ago uh but here we are
and
you know I think that if we're going to
be serious about
getting this taken care of
uh the Now's the Time
the the only thing with the bill that I
would ask is that the bill does not
differentiate as to where that goes and
I and I think that because you can't
just blanketly say well we're just going
to put it into pension debt because the
pension system's broken down into
categories so I would like to see the
bill amended to just have an earmark of
50 50 to group one fifty percent to
group two
I just think that that would just direct
funding
um a little bit rather than just be a
blanket
because you have to you have to
categorize it somewhere
it we we think of things as a giant pot
of money
but and I'm sure Mr Carlin from
retirement can explain that it's not
just exactly a giant pot so
um so that's the only ask I would have
with that but but I do support the
concept any anything to any venture to
pay debt that the state has in any in
any idea I think is good so
thank you for your time with this and uh
and I'll certainly entertain any
questions you may or may not have
questions
seeing none thank you thank you very
much and we'll get together with Marty
and see if we can't figure out a
distribution as you suggested
alrighty
thank you Mr chair again for the record
Marty Carlin from the New Hampshire
retirement system
um just wanted to to build on what the
sponsors just said and also it was a
question that came up last week that I
have a partial answer on that I can
share with this group
um you know last week when when uh
representative of the retirement system
was testifying he you know correctly
said that you know there's no you know
if people want to give us money you know
we don't have any philosophical
objections or statutory uh problems
accepting payments over and above but I
do want to clarify that our our board
hasn't taken a position on this bill we
do see it as policy which is completely
on this side of the river and we
wouldn't necessarily a pine on it one
way or the other just but in general
terms again you know we're not going to
say no uh to additional funding towards
the end liability
question that came up is well you know
how how might that work you know if we
gave you X what's how's that going to
help and and
um you know essentially any any
appropriation under this bill would be
you know would just be exed off an
amount of the unfunded liability which
is currently at the end of the last
fiscal year 5.69 billion uh it's a large
number most of that 5 billion five plus
billion is scheduled to be paid off by
um as part of the initial legislative
changes to amortize it over 30 years
um I I did reach out to the actuary
because you know
Appropriations are so time dependent I
couldn't say oh if we had a 100 million
120 million dollars for a plus in 2028
what is it going to do it you know we
couldn't tell you with any degree of
certainty but as a hypothetical I asked
um if if nhrs last if this was in effect
you know with the current State Surplus
so we got a an approach 50 million
towards the unfunded liability that
would increase employer contribution
rates uh by between 0.1 and 0.2 percent
of payroll depending on the member group
if it was distributed sort of evenly if
if we have a different distribution
method that may change it a little but
essentially that would be a 4.1 million
less in contributions we'd be asking
employers for in 24. so you know okay
you're putting 50 million up front but
but that's you know that the rates would
be that would be a permanent increase
um because we have that money you know
in the bank and being invested so it's
not a one-year savings you're you're
accruing that over time
um you know you'll you'll get more than
you put in uh
you know um based on the investment
income
I think you got representative McGuire's
attention representative McGuire
not specifically but was representative
Pearson correct that you think of the
unfunded liability as there's so much
group one unfunded liability there's so
much group two unfunded liability or
maybe there's other categories be you
know for
financial accounting and Actuarial
purposes all four plans employee
teaching police teachers police and
fired liabilities are calculated uh
separately there are different
assumptions for the you know group one
and group two and things like that so
that's one of the reasons you know when
because the employer rates are developed
separately for those four groups as well
so you know there are in our annual
reports
um you know a funded ratio for the fire
plan and for the teacher's plan so you
know and then the numbers that we tend
to speak to with the committee is the
aggregate number for the whole plan
which is
65.6 funded actually brought uh copies
of all of our annual reports and our
current statute book I was going to drop
a copy off with uh this claim and for a
reference for the finance office at a
copy for LBA as well
um to go in and I think those numbers
that I'm speaking to are actually in our
valuation which is posted on our website
but so there are different liabilities
um you know for different funding ratios
for the respective groups I think most
recently the group two plans are have a
better funded ratio even though the
rates are are that much you know higher
and and percent of pay uh and part of
that with some
legislation back in the 2000s and early
2010s moving money from the special
account and from medical subsidy
accounts and things like that and that
money was credited to the group two
plans uh because it was taken out
um for the insurance uh piece for the
special account for them so you know and
you know there's some you know in the
teacher plan is as I definitely the the
lowest funded of the four and that's
sort of a function of that lowering head
count that we've seen so so there are
variations you know on the plan level
um I think you know without specific
guidance we would probably look at if
you know yeah I don't want to speak for
the actuary but I think they'd look as
you know the employee population is
about 50 percent of the total membership
teachers are about 35 you know that we
any of these funding infusions could
theoretically be you know would probably
most logically without other direction
just apply them as a percentage are the
size of the total group if if the bill
was amended with rapid as Senator
Pearson you know it would you know more
money going towards group two is than
their proportion of the membership would
lower those rates more those are the
highest rates those are the ones we hear
most about from employers so you know
there's some policy considerations uh
for you all and how you would want to
distribute any of these Appropriations
um that would be up to you guys we
wouldn't have have a position on what
you'd tell you to do that
yeah follow up so do you think that the
bill as written is unimplementable
because of this question or would you
have to adopt rules or something that
decide that make that decision you know
I mean when we looked at it we we
haven't done a you know a 360 on that
specific question I I think you know the
the working assumption was you know that
you know administratively what what's
the what's the most reasonable
perspective and you know again if we you
know applying it to the
to each group as a percentage of their
size of the total
seems logical but you know there are
other reasonable arguments and can be
made for another one
um you know if the legislature or an
employer group wanted to challenge that
then we'd have to kind of figure out
where to go from there but um you know
that
um you know we haven't drilled down that
far it was a question that we didn't
contemplate
representative Wilder thank you Mr chair
I have a question on the five-year
smoothing that was used to uh
adopt an a rate of return that was that
was used to assess the rates that people
paid for the thing I remember that the
90s we were running at better than nine
percent
Returns on this and then we got to 2000
we had a big drop in 2001 and for the
whole
10 years of of the 2000s first 10 years
um
it barely made five percent and yet
the retirement system kept assuming
eight and a half most of the time
through there and the Delta kept growing
and I kept criticizing the system over
why are you doing this because you're
making the Delta grow bigger and they
say oh we have five year smoothie is
that a law or a rule uh it's it's a it's
an Actuarial practice it's it's within
you know the Actuarial standards to do
that I mean you know
you know the board could adopt a policy
to smooth over four years or six years
but there's a range in most plans do the
five-year smoothing I you know I can't
speak for why the board kept the assumed
rate of return at eight and a half
percent until I think it was um 2011 uh
after that of 2005 to 10 experience then
when they lowered it for seven and three
quarters now it's it's currently six and
uh three quarters
um you know partially though
on in the night of the no folks the new
folks aren't going to be
get the the reference but the special
account was something that had been in
saturated for a number of years and it
took any percentage over the assumed
rate of return and segregated it for
colas and medical benefits and and there
was almost a perverse incentive to have
a higher assumed rate of return so
you're catching some of the stuff that
would have flowed into the special
account and that was repealed 911. and
so that that may be some of the history
there for the board's thinking but again
I wasn't here to watch
and we discovered another significant
difference in in the 90s when we were
assessing uh cost of living increases
from the excess that went into the
special fund and that was that and one
of my friends was a fireman said oh
they're prejudice against the firemen
but this was the truth
um a lot of people get into teaching
they pay so much into the system and so
does the employer if you leave before
you're vested you take all the money
that you contributed but the money that
the employer contributed stays in the
fund so there was much more Surplus in
the teacher fund than there was in
either police or fire fire had the least
Surplus because most firemen stayed for
a whole career police a little less so
but teachers did not stay as long
especially since they'd have to do like
a 30-year career and go to age 65 so it
was interesting how those things varied
as well and that's another thing that
has to be taken into account thank you
that's very interesting and it's
teachers I'm teachers uh firefighters
are still the group that retires with
the most years of service on average
when they go out
um you know and you know a little bit
higher age than police and that so that
that's held and even when I talk about
the retirement rates in recent years
it's been more on the police and the
Fireside
um
that's
so Marty maybe uh tomorrow or the next
day you could give us some more
hypotheticals you gave a really good one
with the 50 million in the savings but
giving some more hypotheticals might be
worthwhile to look at we like looking at
numbers and yeah I can see what they can
turn around for us you know but again if
we're if it's an infusion that's coming
you know years down the road it's like I
don't think they're even going to be
comfortable calculating it just because
I mean I asked them for 50 and 100 and
you know 50 was 4.1 Million last 100
million was 8.1 million less so you know
they they it's just fairly linear you
know you can just pick the number and
apply that percentage to it but um I can
see what
um
what if anything may be comfortable
doing with this but again in so much
it's
timing you know and even even Market
timing you know oh we got 50 million and
the markets took off and we have much
better off than if it went the other way
in that year but
um
you know so so we'll see what I can do
but I don't think I can promise much
more than sort of the real broad brush
here
not even a broad brush is good uh so you
were you said that the retirement system
is not supportive I had notes now I know
you weren't here at the last week when
they some an attorney I believe came in
represent and he stated that the
retirement system supported that so you
taken that back I guess yes spiritually
supported it but not officially and we
haven't brought it to the board okay
just yeah
you know we we try to try to stay out of
policy issues and other than giving
numbers and things like that um
sometimes we Veer over that you know
line occasionally by accident we want to
try to walk it back if we do
no I thought it was great as I'm one of
the sponsors of the bill that I thought
was a great statement to thank Tony I
think it's a very good bill personally
and maybe needs a couple little tweaks
but any other further questions uh
representative Weiler
I I see these two bills as as being
comparable they both have an attempt to
reduce property taxes I think this bill
does more to reduce property taxes long
term than 50. 50 is likely to be a
one-time thing and it's it's such a
small piece of the 1.3 billion that we
do for property tax relief that I don't
think I think it would get swallowed up
and rounding virtually but this this uh
hopefully will have a big amount plus I
like the fact that we can control it
it's not a loose end if we see this
Surplus then we have a good place to put
it rather than saying okay we're going
to put more money there but we don't
know how much it will be
I liked from the standpoint of doing
budgets I like this bill much better
than 50. thank you
thanks any further questions
seeing none will close the work session
up Tony sure
just briefly unless I misheard I believe
previous speakers said that putting this
extra money would increase the employee
payment I assume he misspoke but that's
how I took I think it was a mistake
right right and and the other thing as
far as the idea of deciding which uh
product goes into I have no objection to
that I would just suggest that it be
worded such that if one of them is paid
off that the money would go to the
others okay thank you
thank you uh seeing no further questions
up Miss heck
thank you representative before you
close a hearing I did want to take the
opportunity to say that we strongly
support this legislation on behalf of
the cities and towns that we represent
this is a long-term strategy it will
have long-term positive implications it
will reduce property taxes and while we
won't see immediate benefits maybe in 24
or 25 until the actuaries start to redo
the calculations we will see long-term
benefits over time with 75 to 80 percent
of our costs being on the unfunded
liability so I just wanted to say we
very much support this legislation thank
you
thank you very much and somebody just
whispered in my ear they might like to
make a motion so I'd recognize uh
representative McGuire
so I'd move off to pass
emotions been made and seconded seconded
by representative Weiler will give the
clerk just a minute to get his paperwork
together
sure go ahead yes the motion is ought to
pass was there a consideration to amend
it uh or is it going to be just like
this just like this
representative Maguire's likes to take a
jump every once in a while
[Laughter]
and certainly why the clerk is getting
ready uh is there any discussion on the
motion
yeah I'll explain why so I think I don't
this to me seems like good policy but
it's somewhat aspirational in the sense
that I don't think the rainy day fund
has ever been big enough to cause this
to trigger
right and so this is something that's
maybe if we're lucky is going to happen
way down the road
um but it's good policy and we ought to
imply it um also what often happens in
the budget is things like this get
overridden right and so so it's it's
it's
yeah
so it's good policy but but it may or
may not actually happen I guess is my
point
good question thank you Mr chair yeah
yeah I agree I think I I like it uh my
question was more what we discussed
earlier in that we needed to Define what
portions would go to the different
groups so would an amendment be required
or would that be something we would do
later
uh as it's been presented would pass as
is now anyone's free to offer an
amendment safe before the full committee
if they thought it was necessary
Mr Clark
Hospital five
hi
yes
so sorry vote being unanimous uh
ought to pass goes forward at a vote of
nine to zero
eight I believe eight eighties excuse me
a to zero
thank you very much and thanks for your
testimony everybody out there
representative buco
uh now we're gonna hear House Bill 311
FNA making an appropriation to the
Department of Environmental Services for
eligible Wastewater projects known
affectionately to a lot of us as Buco
bucks
representative Buco yes thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee
so my for the record my name is Tom Buco
I'm uh
a representative of Carroll County
District 2 uh district one changed
um
and I'm here I'm here today to introduce
House Bill 311 and to ask that uh the
committee
um
find this bill ought to pass
or retain
um
as you mentioned in in the past
we've been we've been submitting so this
let me just go over this quickly if this
is there's a state aid grant program
that
um
supplements
or
it's waste water projects
and and many of you will recognize that
I've been in this I've been submitting
these bills for about 13 years now
there used to be level funded program
however
at in um
when the governor ex by executive order
swept out the account it's taken us 13
years to catch up to catch up
so the intent of this bill is to is not
to fund a particular list of projects as
the others were but to level fund this
program so that it
so that the funding is there
and and we don't have to submit these
lists every every actually every two
years
um
the uh the fiscal note explains
the amounts
and shows uh and shows you that
where the where the funding where the
funding requests
are this year
I think um
also
um Mr chairman I would like to introduce
an amendment and I don't know what your
process is in this committee for doing
that
have you given a copy to uh
the LBA or
uh no I just had it drafted I just had
an unapproved copy unapproved Amendment
drafted at OLS now you can certainly
speak to your
Amendment it's a simple it's simple it's
just what I just said about
submitting this particular list of
projects every two years instead of
doing that this funding will go into
maintenance or efficiency what's called
efficiency the efficiency account now
and and instead of instead of having to
to um
instead of having to submit the list
every every two years this will be a
level funded program and the so the the
uh the amendment all the amendment says
is that it shall be non-lapsing
and that'll that'll keep the program
going so that so so
what happens with these projects is that
you know you first have to get local uh
um approvals to issue the bonds then you
have to have all the engineering then
you have the construction and then it's
about 10 years by the time it it gets to
the point where it's got one year of
um substantial completion and that's the
only time that that's when the funding
comes in after the after all of that is
done after the project is complete so
it's it's kind of hard to to
there are the these lists are just
estimates and the costs are estimates
so
by level funding the program and by
keeping it non-lapsing they'll be
they'll be the funds will be in the
program every year and the
municipalities will have confidence in
in applying for the for the for the
program and the department will have
funding to be able to put towards these
projects
and I I think I'll just stop there and
take questions if if I can
questions for representative buco
yep
just just for clarity
um
what you're saying is before
doing what you're proposing here towns
are
uh would be in the position to have to
commit to a project without knowing full
well that those funds are going to be
available for them and this this would
alleviate that question mark is that
another way of putting it yes yes that
that's correct uh representative in fact
what used to be called the delayed and
deferred list were projects that went
ahead got completed and then then the
state reneged on the funding and that's
that's what started the uh the uh the
delayed and deferred list and and as I
said it's taken us 14 15 years to catch
up
and that last year we finally caught up
actually
um
and so
so that municipalities don't have to go
ahead and issue bonds and go through all
the construction and then find out that
they're not going to get the money that
the state it's in law it's RSA 486 it's
in law and they should they should be
able to have confidence that they're
going to be that they're going to get
the funding when the project is done
further questions represent McGuire
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative
so I represent the town of Epsom I don't
believe that anyone
ever I believe that everyone in our town
has their own septic system
so why should my constituents be paying
for these kind of systems for others
so
the purpose of these
um grants was to incentivize
municipalities to
to to um come up to standards what what
um
on with with their with their wastewater
treatment and collection
um
in order to keep the groundwater clean
rippers was the groundwater
um
it's it's there's if there's no
there's no there's no uh Community
um Wastewater collection in Epsom at all
and nothing
I don't believe so we do have a small
water district with a with a community
well for part of our town There's this
kind of like an older part of town that
had smaller Lots they have a community
well but but I don't there's no
wastewater treatment plant or anything
like that
so this this program started many years
ago and as I said the incentive was to
keep the groundwater cleaned
and so it um
it was based on municipalities
if I could for representative bucco one
of the things that you need in a state
or wastewater treatment plants to treat
septids from septic tanks so that's one
of the other features of this
legislation that you have a place to
take your accepted so in his town for
instance those folks have a place to
take their percentage thank you that's
that's correct thank you
representative Hewitt followed by
representative Weiler
no I I think we've all received this
this piece that you mailed it to all the
members right municipal
state aid and revenue sharing it has a
piece on page 14
pointing out
276 million dollars came to the state
from the Exxon Mobil mtbe lawsuit which
went to a trust fund in 18 member
commission uh comprised of state and
local officials is giving out loans and
they've given out so far 125 million
that may have affected why other parts
of the state budget didn't put as much
money into this as they had previously
because there was another source of
Revenue thank you
thanks I representative Weiler anything
else represent a buco
uh
no
one of the things in the past for those
of you that haven't been on this
division we often retain this and have
put it in the budget that's not to say
we wouldn't do that again we could act
on it one way or the other today or hold
on to it and see what the governor's
budget has included because I noted uh
on the fiscal node it says the these
amounts have been included in the
Department's operating budget requests
for 20 24 and 2025 as additional
prioritized need requests so it would
appear maybe Des has got them in their
budget but we'll find out shortly
what
what I can show you here is
this is the this is the Department's
request
and for this particular account
and they under efficiency there's
there's zero so they're not they're not
carrying forward
um the the projects that are already
have already been started getting
payments that's what that would be in
the efficiency budget what they have
here is is um
additional prioritized needs
and those are
generally considered the the new the new
projects that they expect to come online
during the during this biennium
we have the Department of Environmental
Services coming in tomorrow at 1 pm so
we'll try to get that cleared up thank
you yes thank you ma'am
oh
yeah if once representative Buco is
finished if you'd like to come forward
and state your name for the record
please
thank you Mr chairman
thanks
oh there we go thank you so much hi
Tracy wood I'm the administrator of the
Wastewater engineering Bureau at New
Hampshire Des which resides in the Water
Division under rainy Pelletier
so maybe you can clear up any confusion
as far as the Department's support or
not support or including these figures
in the budget coming forward
yes happy to do so
so when we prepared our budget for the
24-25 biennium we were held at uh three
percent increase from our 23 budget for
this particular line item state aid
grant
for the 20 fiscal year 23 budget it was
actually funded from a 21 Surplus monies
and so when you look at our budget the
line item says zero for fiscal year 23
and 3 percent of zero dollars is zero
dollars so we could not carry it in our
operating budget so what we did is we
carry we carried it as I prioritized
need and so that is in our request
for segment users in our request as a
prioritized need
budgeting huh
so is everybody as confused as I am or
yeah
yeah exactly yeah
right it's an addition to their budget
exactly exactly in a normal year we
would have an allotment like fiscal year
23 like we would have carried in our
normal budget
a line item amount but we didn't because
it came from Surplus for 21 which got
carried over it's all semantics but yes
we normally carry monies in our budget
every fiscal year for maintenance
payments for state aid grant
any further questions
representative Griffin
evil
I thought I saw a question on your face
have you seen the
um
amounts that are needed to upgrade these
wastewater treatment plants greatly
increasing because of increasing
pollutants that are coming in like pfas
new standards that sort of thing
what we're dealing with right now is
last year was the celebration of 50
years of the Clean Water Act and that's
when the majority of our wastewater
treatment facilities were built and some
communities over time put monies into
their infrastructure others did not so
much so we're dealing with aging
infrastructure is the biggest piece and
then yes New Hampshire is not a
delegated State EPA region one is our
permitting Authority and yes every
permit that comes out is always more
stringent than the previous permit they
never get less stringent they they get
more stringent so what we're dealing
with
mainly right now is nutrient issues
metal issues yes we are seeing uh EPA
has putting pfas monitoring in nifty's
permits but it's just monitoring and it
actually hasn't even started yet because
we're waiting for EPA to come out with a
validated method before they give the go
ahead for communities to start
monitoring for pfas in their systems
and I don't know in the long run with
wastewater treatment you know pfas is
is a huge issue and it's just not going
to be economical to to treat at the
wastewater treatment facilities on a
large scale and that's why you'll see in
the permit that EPA is targeting
industrial facilities and looking at
those sources within the collection
system to try to address it at the
source instead of at the end pipe right
because wastewater treatment facilities
they're not generating pfas they're the
receivers of pfas and so trying to stop
it before it gets there
follow-up
I would just say I've introduced a bill
to help with some of that already and I
think the focusing on the front end is
uh is really important Mr chair can I
just I'm sorry to ask this these
historical things but the state aid
grant program
folks basically come up with their
construction and maintenance ideas and
they presented at a fairly basic level
to Des and it's kind of guaranteed you
get 20 or how
much of a lift is it to get the 20 if
that's what I read here about 486
I may be wrong so what happens is uh the
state a grant program is an after the
fact grant program so it's once a
project is complete then they come in
with an application and we review that
application and then they'll get between
20 and 30 percent it depends on
different criteria that we have and
they'll get an award based on their
principal and interest payments over the
life of their loan and I will say
um you know representative Buco made a
an excellent comment I'm having a lot of
conversations with communities right now
and you know they want to know about
state aid grant they want to know is
this active is it up because this may be
the one piece that gets them to the
finish line so we're working with
communities to leverage different
funding sources and then like say they
came in for clean water srf loan and it
was a million dollar project and then
we'll offer them maybe a certain amount
of subsidy say maybe we can give them 20
to 30 percent and so you'll take that
off the top so say you had a million
dollar loan we're giving you 30 subsidy
you're down to 700 000. then they get to
that point they may look at other
sources too like Northern borders rural
development there's lots of funding
sources but then when they get that
final amount then they'll say okay if
state aid grant is active I'm going to
get 20 to 30 percent on that remaining
seven hundred thousand that's going to
help me with my payments over time and
it'll attenuate the impacts to the users
on the system and the rate increases
over time is what it does
representative evil is never a bad
question
well I was going to say just getting to
uh representative Maguire's point and
then uh about you know there are towns
that don't have uh right
um and then representative or chair
liegeman pointed out we all need some
place to put our own individual septage
but that's true also for land landfill
leachate right correct there's the waste
the landfill leeche comes from the
landfills where a lot of our stuff goes
to the wastewater treatment plants so
they really provide sort of a global
service they do
um part of the bill monies that we're
receiving so clean water srf is
receiving emerging contaminants monies
not as much as they're receiving on the
drinking water side and we're utilizing
those monies for projects to address
landfill leachate again stopping it at
the source breaking that cycle before it
gets to the wastewater treatment plant
so any community that has a municipal
landfill that discharges to their
Municipal wastewater treatment facility
can come in for a project and get a
grant North Conway is coming in they're
our first project and they're going to
be looking at the treatment different
piloting different technology to see how
they can treat the landfill leachate so
that it's
cleaner before it gets sent to the
wastewater treatment plant there's
limited funds in that but it's still
some funds and that's a hundred percent
Grant so those projects won't be coming
in for sag
represent Weiler
thank you Mr chair
uh reading in the calf or that uh
Des has chosen 12 parts per trillion for
pfas which no one else has chosen and I
don't believe there's any scientific
evidence for such choice and now it's in
court can you give us any update on
where it stands
that I cannot I I follow pfas up here
but I look at it as you know what's in
how it's impacting my Wastewater
Treatment Facility so on the setting of
any levels
and the science of that I I stay back
perhaps you when the folks come in
tomorrow you can let them know that
question may be asked sure happy to do
that
Mr Hoffman
I just wanted to add a couple of points
that I think are important one is
funding for these projects was included
in House Bill 2 which you could argue as
part of the budget and therefore should
be part of the budget going forward
because it's a 20-year commitment
these are for Approved project project
projects
they've already been awarded and gone to
government Council
the department has Specific Instructions
for preparing their budget but I think
you could argue very strongly that this
should be should have been part of the
base budget
thanks Michael any further Miss wood or
any other questions
all right thank you thank you very much
bill
you state your name for the record
please
thank you very much
uh my name is Bill Hansel
um I've worked on this bill in 1989.
so I've been involved in it for a bit of
time I was formerly in the house from 84
to 87 I was vice chairman of House
Education committee
uh but I've been following water since I
was a Precinct commissioner in 77 in
Conway Village
and then a selectment in Conway and then
to the House of Representatives I've
been involved in water from most of my
life my father was a master of plumber
so I grew up in the plumbing family
excuse me I know the value of water bill
I think our clerk has a question because
I just need to know who you're speaking
on behalf I'm speaking on behalf of
Granite State Rural Water Association as
a policy analyst for that entity and I'm
representing what's Conway water
Precinct in lower Bartlett water
Precinct
two
North and South areas of Mount
Washington Valley
um
North Conway actually filed the uh the
bill in 89.
and created the state aid grant back in
the 70s you realized the feds had
I think it was a
the state had 20 and the local was five
and that's how most of these Wastewater
plants were built back in those days
a lot of them are aging of course and
there's a great need to upgrade them but
there's a greater need to expand them uh
to to get to areas that
don't have the ability to have on-site
soar for affordable housing so it Blends
in with the state need to address that
as well as protecting its rivers and
it's uh and it's water sources
the the state aid grant I think
representative Emrick said it very well
I taught representative Buco in his long
enduring Relentless efforts with his
bills every year since 2008 in
particular has been the suspenders to
the line item belt
and I thought that was a good analogy
that that represent americh laid forward
the pants fell down in 2008 they almost
looked at the knees
when Tom is billed every year has until
last session has been pulling him up
last session thanks to a bipartisan
effort and all you folks we got the belt
at the waist level
the problem is it's it's about to sink
again
at a time when there's an awful lot of
federal money coming in that would help
us
this this is a three-legged stool a
federal state and local funding
and I'm I'm always representing the
local effort as is representative Buco
because we came from that history and
that knowledge
the bonds wouldn't pass at the local
level to do the amazing amount of work
that's being done without that state and
Grant partnership
and the people pass those bonds within
with the understanding of the law says
the state shall pay so it's uh it's more
a moral battle the law is there it's
just uh it's it's in the legislature
it's an educational battle uh it's quite
complex unless you've lived at the local
level and followed it all the way
through but what happens what this bill
does in essence especially the
non-lapsing which we're trying to get in
this session
if if that's successful we might be able
to do away with the suspenders going
forward
the non-lapsing
would allow the the money that you put
in the House Bill too because all this
bill is really doing is allowing us to
get in at the beginning ground level we
had a presentation of the Finance on the
on a bill and have a dissertation all
the way through to try to get the
language in the house bill to the
trailer bill that describes how those
funds will go to the municipalities
a couple of sessions ago it was
clarified for the first time that this
money in the state aid grant isn't the
Des budget it's money that passes from
the general fund of the people back to
the people in this Partnership of a
partnership of long-term debt so uh
payments and principal interest on their
on a local debt
and the local debts could be I think
it's probably 250 million anyway of
construction yes and we're only asking
to support it at a flat line level of
about 15 million a year
and non-lapse it so that the agency the
engineering Bureau can can have that
money when those projects are done are
what we say done they have to be
certified as completed and then this has
to be a one-year warranty
and those community and then usually the
bonds for the federal government whether
it's rural development or state
revolving long fund come due a year
after so they have the money non-lapsing
means that money is there when that
certification is ready to go to
government Council
this also takes the
really clarifies that any direction from
the governor to put a percentage
reduction on all bureaucracies like they
did in 2008 would not affect this
funding it from the bureaucracy's point
of view and if it's long-lapsing and
it's there
it still isn't spent because it has to
go to government Council for approval
they still then at that point would have
the latitude to decide what the state
can do on the economic conditions
but the fact that we're closing the Gap
and not waiting for a next session of
legislations was possible new changes of
legislation not understanding the
program
uh not not putting the money forward you
have that time frame and in that time
frame municipalities abound in health to
make those payments whether the state's
money is there or not and that's what
we've been facing for a long time it's
been a magnificent unanimous support
last session Bolton House Finance in the
house and in the full Senate to support
this but I'm I'm hoping we can clarify
the non-lapsing as representative Google
understands it and brought forward in
this amendment and then in conclusion uh
Senate rashadi I've been working with
has filed Senate Bill 230 which
was filed after this bill in the
non-lapsing part is in there if you look
at the language of SB 230
it's it's also describes that the
non-lapsing means that any money that
doesn't go to the efficiency budget
which the Des calls a maintenance budget
can be brought forward and then can be
used to reward new projects according to
the approval of government Council it
takes a des out of the politics of the
money it puts it in the hands of the
governor Council whether they want to
cut the money or because they don't have
it
but the people bypassing those bonds can
start to have a reliable feeling that
the state is a is a solid partner and
then I should point out too that as far
as a 20 or 30 percent
uh
all the projects we've that we did in
North Conway uh we we already had
our debt our rate payment three times
the state average I think it is it's a
certain average of your rate set once it
hits that level you're eligible for the
30 percent
I've stood in front of people voting on
the bonds and said raise your rates to
the level of unaffordability
and then you get an extra 10 percent
and then you've got skin in the game
because in New Hampshire trust fund they
all say we want skin in the game so now
the locals raise their rates because
they're going to have to anyway to to
pay the construction but why not raise
it and pay as much as you can on rates
and get 10 more on the long-term uh
Partnership of the state so that's a
strategy whether they do it locally or
not it's up to them but but the local
government the local municipalities are
more than willing to do what the
regulatory drivers are ordering some to
they only ask that it's affordable
and what makes it affordable the
formulas of the state and federal
government municipalities at the local
level are willing to accept those
affordable formulas
so we're not trying to dictate anything
we're trying to by their by the state
and federal formulas make it affordable
with a state a grant program
it's solid program it's a solid
partnership and we can do much that has
to be done within the state Rivers water
protection Lakes Protections in
conjunction with forests it's just all
one thing but the essence of water
depends on this state aid grant if you
want a lot of construction to occur
thank you
thank you for the opportunity to have to
give that long dissertation
thanks Bill
seeing no further questions uh the
pleasure of the division concerning 311.
we'll uh hold on to it and see what the
budget looks like Tom
foreign
having this
just give that to Mr Hoffman if you
would
you know and we can take that up at a
later date
thanks
well right on time almost uh
we'll be back here at one o'clock so
you're free to take an extended lunch
look at that
okay
organization
yes
everybody
all right
information last night evidence
yeah so the work session
during a series
like
it's unfortunately I was in the building
all day and it was my own bill and I
didn't come down because I bought it so
so
let this take a few minutes a lot of
handouts that have come up we're just
kind of going through them first
foreign
's already made sure that they've given
us quite a few but you can certainly
wait until we're ready thanks
okay
but it's like an existing bridge in this
picture
all right representative Pearson uh
this is House Bill 506
relative to the construction of a rail
trail box tunnel on exit 4A and Dairy
and making an appropriation there of
are there for
good afternoon Mr chairman
members of finance division one for the
record Representative Steve Pearson
Rockingham District 13. which
encompasses the town of Derry
when I turned six
years old they started talking about the
construction of exit 4A
a lot has happened since I was six
[Music]
and for the most part what hadn't
happened was anything to do with exit 4A
delay delay delay the Department of
Transportation has delayed this project
in some form or another since 1982.
so fast forward to
a couple years ago
and things really start kind of jumping
into gear here
so I'm not going to touch on the test
technical aspects of it I have people
behind me that are here to do that what
I'm going to talk about is is my town
Dairy
in the last two years I've had 34
meetings 34 meetings with stakeholder
groups the Department of Transportation
handicapped folks
and the like on this
issue
for the most part
up until recently
the plans that were presented to the
folks in my town
involved in tunnel that just went under
six Lanes of traffic it's a logical
thing to do it
it's done in many many locations
throughout the state
and then
out of the blue
and a concept came out
with this
spaghetti thing that you guys are
looking at
we never actually had an official public
hearing until September
of 2022 to discuss this at this point
it was really just a dictation to the my
constituents and it wasn't really a
public hearing
so
you can imagine the shock and surprise
of the leaders of at the Town level and
the state level when you have something
that's gone forward for a long time
with pretty much the same way
and then all of a sudden
an alternative idea comes about
one of the other things that I'd like to
address before we start getting heavy
into this is an apology to this
committee during
last week when the speaker's office sent
out a series of emails in reference to
the rescheduling of hearings due to
inclement weather
the work session notification for this
day was included in a in a series of
emails that went out
myself and several others were under the
impression that the public hearing had
been rescheduled to today
that is why you did not see very many
folks at the public hearing despite
hundreds of people that had signed in on
the blue sheet
so that's kind of the situation we're in
today and I again would apologize to the
committee for that mistake
but during that testimony
the Department of Transportation decided
to represent the opinion of the town of
Derry and they did not do so correctly
so much so that the chairman of the Town
Council has sent me something to read
and he is not happy
so I will if it's okay with you I will
read what what the chairman of the Town
Council said is I think this is
extraordinarily relevant to our
circumstances and I will get you with
this in in writing form hi my name is
Josh Borden I'm the dairy Town councilor
at large and chairman finishing my ninth
year first I'd like to thank you all for
your service and recognizing my
testimony I would be there in person but
I am teaching political science at
Windham High School
second in the in the words in this
letter are mine and not reflective of my
colleagues on the council
I was disappointed to hear some of the
testimony being given by the D.O.T
during representative Pearson's Bill
hearing on the rail trail tunnel
the fact is I never voted in favor of
the alternative scenic route plan
approximately one month prior to our
vote I called for a meeting with
representative Pearson Town manager Dave
Karen members of The Dot and vice chair
Aaron Spencer Town Council Vice chair
Aaron Spencer to ask questions about
each of the plans tunnel versus
the alternative the cost to Dairy
taxpayers and potential delays I heard
from hundreds of constituents regarding
their desire for the tunnel the only
time that I have seen the community this
fired up was when a radical counselor
closed a fire station
during the meeting with the D.O.T I was
assured of three things one they wanted
the town to be happy with the end result
two the dairy taxpayer would not have to
pay for the tunnel if we chose to go
that route and three there would be
delays to the project likely lasting six
months to a year
after hearing this I felt it was my
obligation to my colleagues as well as
the constituents to agendize this item
and bring forward a vote on whether the
Town Council supported the scene the
tunnel or scenic route
to my dismay the town received a letter
a few days prior to the vote in a
nutshell the letter stated that the town
would likely have to pay the cost of the
tunnel the dot reversed their decision
as chairman I was infuriated with the
confusion in reversal the council had
always said that they were not willing
or able to spend more money on the exit
4A project beyond our five million
dollar obligation
I we per public testimony were
indifferent on the rail trail plans if
we were to pay however if we were given
the choice to upshift the cost then the
tunnel may have passed
in my opinion the vote that we
eventually took said that we were
indifferent with the current terms and
would not take the risk of having to pay
for a tunnel
it would have been interesting to see
what would have happened had the dot not
reversed their stance I am personally
asking you to Value the safety of the
residents tourists from all over the
world who will be using this Trail value
the economics of a vibrant well-built
Rail Trail
and to support funding the tunnel I am
always willing to wait for something
that will better Mike will be better for
my community and the state we share
thank you Josh Borden chairman
of the Derry Town Council
one of the things that
happened in the history of this was that
the the towns of Darien Londonderry
signed a contract with the state it's a
single document signed by both towns
indicating their financial obligation
the town of dairy FL floated a bond to
pay for that five million dollars that
was that was conducted years ago
so to have the Department of
Transportation send a threatening letter
and that's what it was it was a threat
to the Derry Town Council
for them not to interfere with what the
D.O.T was doing otherwise there would be
Financial penalties involved I think was
unethical
it violated the conditions of the
contract and it's certainly nothing I
had ever seen before from state
government down to the local level
we're in a peculiar situation here if
you go up and down 93 and you get off an
exit you exit onto a state road right
Exit 4 is 102. Exit 3 is 111. but in
this particular case exit 4A exits onto
town roads
so the circumstances of
what you would I would consider a normal
type of exit where the Department of
Transportation controls both the highway
and the road that it exits onto is not
the case here
so it's
it's a it's an Avenue that I think was
confusing for folks it's been confusing
for me
as to how where that separation is and
who was allowed to do what and who
controls what
but we're well into the town of Derry
by the time you get to this Railroad Bed
the rail trail and dairy has been
through the efforts of a lot of
volunteers
become a
very popular
part of a State trail system
it's paved for the most part
it's in the University of New Hampshire
has done usage studies it is heavily
used
then rightly so you have a great walking
path it's safe you very little
interactions with automobiles it's a
place where you can bring pets kids in
strollers bikes that sort of thing
we actually have two businesses in Dairy
that have popped up because of the trail
that's how popular it is
so when this came about
when we looked at this
immediate concerns came up because the
design requires a crosswalk across six
Lanes of traffic now folks have a
tendency to kind of just
go the straight path
and this alternative plan that you see
here
it goes so far out of the way that The
Logical move is I'm just going to hit a
button and I'm going to do the Frogger
thing and I'm going to go across six
Lanes of traffic to continue on to the
other side
the Town Council doesn't want it the
town manager doesn't want it
I as a 27-year safety professional don't
like it
and I look at this and I say okay
what's the logical move here what's been
done in other places
and it's simply been a concrete box
tunnel the concrete box tunnel is so
small it's not even big enough to fit in
the finance room
that's how that's how small this tunnel
is it's not big at all
but the idea here is to replace it with
almost a quarter mile of pavement that
runs at us that it angles that are on
the cusp of ADA compliance
that are in one side almost two football
fields in length
and that goes runs along a brook that's
flooded
massively flooded three times in my
lifetime I grew up in Dairy
so this whole thing doesn't even pass
the sniff test it's illogical
it's not good for the the rail trail
system itself it's gonna I don't even
know what it's going to do to the race
that we hold we hold a a running race a
charity race on the rail trail
I don't know how that's going to work
I'm very concerned about the
interactions between bicyclists and
pedestrians I mean I'm very concerned
about blind corners
in in an amazing bit of
I won't call it hypocrisy because I
don't know that it's that but in by
comparison the Department of
Transportation had concerns about the
slope of the road over the Box tunnel
and they were concerned at the six six
and seven degree Mark in an automobile
but they don't seem to be concerned
about a pedestrian at five degrees
so we worked with them shaved a foot off
the top of it and got those numbers into
a satisfactory
range for the road travel
but the reality here is when the last
tail light from a DOT dump truck drives
away from this project this is on the
town of dairy we're going to have to
maintain it we're going to have to fix
it when it has damage
and we're going to have to deal with the
repercussions of a design
that is highly flawed
so the simple answer was just hey the
federal government was given this plan
years ago and they approved it the
federal government approved the Box
tunnel it met the criteria it met their
safety concerns they gave it the green
light
the plan before you is not approved by
the feds and as of last discussion with
the feds they haven't even seen it
when the August 23rd meeting with the
Department of Transportation that I
attended I was told well if we have the
money it's all about money if we have
the money we'll build the tunnel
well that's why we're here
because we're asking the state as part
of this highway project to appropriate
the money to make this happen
this is something the town of dairy is
going to have to live with for decades
if not a hundred years these box tunnels
have huge lifespans
to undo this later
would be millions of dollars
as you were all aware the time to make
the proper
modifications to things is during the
construction phase
so when I get a letter from the
University a division in the University
of New Hampshire that deals with outdoor
recreation for handicapped folks that's
telling me that this isn't workable
when I have concerns from Runners that I
went to high school with that have
safety concerns about going under a
bridge
into a blind corner
and when I have folks
in my town that use this
to go out with their kids and they're
telling me what's going on with this I I
have no option I have to speak up
so I am I'm not going to get into any
technical aspects there's folks here
that will that will do that and give you
a little bit different you know a little
bit timeline as far as the the state
groups and whatnot but that's that's the
dairy deal
any questions for representative Pearson
representative Wilde
uh thank you Mr Mr chair and thank you
representative Pearson do you know how
how many years this five million dollar
bond has been paid off and and how many
more years to go and my understanding is
Darius already paid it it's done we've
paid we paid the Department of
Transportation and then bonded it in the
town as far as the the town itself
paying back the bond they took out to
pay the dot I'm not aware of when that
but the dot has been paid that's that's
what I've been told thank you
you know it's a good representative
Mount Vernon thank you Mr chair
uh representative what is the current
situation with the rail trail is it is
there no length there currently or what
well the currently the railroad bit is
there it's so that piece of railroad bed
and dairy was used up until 1984.
it's when I you know the uh
it was used for Freight uh the last time
passenger service was sometime in the
1950s but it was used for for Freight
um so the bed is all there there's a
couple of spots where they've had some
little washouts and things like that but
nothing of nothing a consequence but the
the dairy rail trail folks the town of
dairy have done improvements to this up
until the point of 4A because there was
no sense in doing any work in that area
because we knew the highway project was
coming through so it is paved it is it
is done right up until the point of this
construction project it's all ready to
go
follow-up um my question is what did the
red did the railroad cross the street
currently uh when it was in
it it was at street level
it was at street level and there was a
bridge a wooden bridge that on Madden
road that went over the railroad bridge
that bridge was torn down in 86 yes and
just filled in with dirt but yes it went
across
at grade as they call it
any questions over here uh
representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative so do you have this um a
handout from D.O.T I wanted to ask you
some questions related I've seen it so
many times I can probably do it without
it but we can so you said these are town
roads so Folsom Road North High Street
and ferlander these are all town roads
correct correct but they're being re
worked as part of this project correct
they are being reworked as part of the
foray project this actually extends
another even more easterly down Folsom
it crosses not only Route 28 but it goes
all the way down to route 102.
substantial this is a huge swath through
the middle of my town
okay so we don't really have a picture
of what it looks like today well you
have a picture in front of you of the
area of concern here where this where
the tunnel would the Box tunnel would go
through I did hear you over here you
asked representative leishman about
what's the box with the slashes those
are businesses that have been eliminated
due to this project we've lost 13
businesses in Dairy because of this exit
construction so that's those are
structures that are being torn down
um one of which was only is only like
nine years old
Okay so
now you made the statement that people
will be Crossing five Lanes of traffic I
don't see that on this map so on the
left hand side where you see the
building that's being removed
that gray
area is the railroad bed
okay so as a result there's going to be
a crosswalk
on Folsom Road where it comes to that
intersection
and that's the unfortunately the
sidewalks and the rail bed are both gray
so it's hard to
you're not necessarily Zoom I guess on
the maybe on the right hand side that
would probably be better you can that
where it jet where you come north on
High Street and you have what looks like
a bit of a triangle where it slopes to
the right that little jot to the left
that goes across there
that's where there will be a they're
gonna have to put a crosswalk
across that six Lanes of traffic
so that's where you want the rail trail
yes well that's where the rail that's
where the railroad bed pretty much is
and the tunnel would would go underneath
that okay so but I understand that that
if you go to the right with the loop
around and so on that loop around goes
under the full subroad it goes
underneath a bridge that would have to
be lengthened in order to accommodate it
yes
okay but that bridge work is being done
as part of the thing all of this is in a
design phase that none of this even goes
out to bid at earliest October so this
we're not they're not bidding any of
this out yet
I guess my point is people are not
required to cross Folsom Road no on top
they can go underneath they could but
you're right keep in mind you're looking
at a flat map with no gradient
no I mean there's a picture here
that's that's the underneath yeah that
you don't really get a sense of grade
from this either all you're getting
there is just the very loop at the end
how you get to that is 530 feet of 5
degrees on one side and 430 feet back up
on the other
which that photo really does not show
you
yeah you're just seeing the loop that
goes under the bridge
sure but but I guess my point is if
people didn't want to cross Folsom Road
they could turn right take the loop go
underneath and come back yeah they could
but you and I both know that the natural
tendency of people
when they're staring across six lanes
and they see their destination on the
other side is it just they hit the
button we know we're gonna have to deal
with that the town's already trying to
figure out a way to
prepare for that
I I would personally I would rather not
see a crosswalk there period okay but
we're being told that it has to it has
to be put there
right and could I have one more thank
you so you read something from Mr burden
so I have an article here and he's
quoted as saying
um
so where is it here
uh Council chairman Joshua burden says
he supports the trail systems across the
state but his decision which is not to
request this tunnel
was based on the taxpayers on protecting
the taxpayers wallets the best he can it
is unfortunate unfortunate to having to
choose between spending money and not
spending money
um
and I wanted the tunnel I thought it
made sense we just can't
we can't just add a tunnel with the
delays and without the potential costs
to our voters uh that was a no-go for me
from day one
so he's referring to the town of derry's
hook on this yes so so apparently he
wants the tunnel but not enough for
dairy to spend its own money for it
because the town of Jerry bend my
constituents money he's happy for that
because the town of dairy entered into a
contract with the state that outlined
what they would be required to pay and
it when that contract was entered into
the design
elements included that tunnel this is a
change post contract
do you have documentation on that of the
contract yeah I can send it to you sure
okay no problem
yep that's a five million dollar Bond
that's the five million that Dairy and
Londonderry were both required to pay
yeah
it's a single document that both
townside signed
for other questions
I have a couple sure
so I'm looking on the cover sheet here
that we've been looking at into the plan
to the right
and I see
uh what looks to be kind of
spaghetti-ish that goes
around and it says rail trail and that
tiny little you can just barely make it
out
um
oh boy and that really yeah it's it's on
the upper right hand side it's under
your Shield sure yep that's and it says
rail trail that's the proposed that's
really not that's not rail trail correct
that's a proposed
um
how the distance of that new proposal
versus just putting the tunnel in how
many feet is a thousand feet two you
know so the alternative is around just
shy I guess of a quarter mile
um the tunnel itself like I said is
smaller than the finance room
it's it would fit inside it so it's
it's not uh
not it just goes under six Lanes the
width of six Lanes
so further to that the town of dairy
would be responsible for maintaining it
plowing it absolutely the town like I
said when the final dot dump truck
drives away the town of dairy is
responsible not only for the rail trail
for aldermen these are town roads
so now what about the existing rail
trail is that maintained by the trails
Bureau the town of dairy who made so the
the town of dairy has a rail trail
um
committee the chair the president which
is here today will speak to you on on
their specifics but that's a group of
volunteers that maintain it in you know
weeds and garbage and and all that stuff
so
um
I've I've done work with them certainly
over the years and
um they're they're the ones that kind of
just just do that they've raised they've
raised all kinds of money for things
over the years
um to the state still owns that Corridor
is that correct the state owns most of
the corridor
yes yep because they know when all these
lines were abandoned under the law the
state had the first right to acquire the
lines and then subsequently has turned
some of them over to the trails Bureau
but the state of New Hampshire still
owns the underlying property the Dots
here they could they could give you a
better a tighter explanations to the
ownership of
better than I can but yeah that's the
generalized understanding is yes
yeah the state the state owns them their
state property
now
it's interesting that you mentioned that
because New Hampshire is a state law RSA
288 that protects railroad beds that
were in use after 1969. it predicts the
corridors of those for future Commerce
in the event that we ever have to put
freight trains back and if you've ever
been out west oh my God they're
everywhere right so
this railroad bed since it was last used
in 1984 It is Well documented there were
newspaper photos and articles when the
last train came through Dairy it's
certainly not up for dispute here this
particular railroad is a protected
historic corridor
and I would argue that this entire
design violates current state law as it
is a protected historic corridor
in all efforts should be made to fit
within RSA 288 and going way out of the
way to which they're doing here does not
do that
I guess that's where I was going
further questions
I still have a few just want to make
sure everyone oh I'm representative
Hewitt go ahead
I don't particularly have any problem
with with what the town of dairy would
like to do as far as the rail trail is
concerned I think that's entirely your
business and and frankly I don't think
it's any of the business of the finance
committee however
uh there's another there's another issue
that I don't want to get into now if
people are here to talk about the rail
trail and that's what I want them to
talk about but I think everybody needs
to understand that there is also another
issue in here that implicates uh the
criminal law
and this bill uh establishes a the crime
of interfering with the construction of
the rail trail
um
the and it creates a particular type of
crime class A misdemeanor that I think
is entirely within the the jurisdiction
of the Judiciary
sure and I don't think that the finance
committee has any business uh engaging
in a dis decision to uh to to support
and I had an idea a good idea
um but to make it a crime to oppose it
so representative Stapleton filed an
amendment that removes that out in its
entirety ah well I haven't seen that
Amendment so it was it was requested by
OLS to be present here for this work
session
do we have that Mr Hoffman
I believe representative
um Stapleton did send a copy to all of
us but it's technically not to us until
it goes through the LBA so
there we go
and that's fine that's fine
I just wanted to make sure that
everybody understood that wasn't that
was an issue and has nothing to do with
what they're talking about
foreign
thanks Michael
thank you for bringing that up
representative I
I presume that I should know by prison
that you guys had seen that
thank you sir
foreign
Pearson while they're looking at that I
have a few more questions as I continue
to
look at this
so you said the hashed out areas where
buildings that
have been
or are to be removed correct
and who came up with the design to put
the uh
Trail is proposed on the far right side
the alternative rail trail was that so
interestingly enough
a bitter
a competitive bidder during the original
bid build process I believe they call it
that has been abandoned by the DOT
in an attempt
to get an unfair advantage on the other
bidders came up with another design they
invented this thing
so the other two groups that were
bidding on this
it wasn't an apples to Apple's bid
they've submitted an alternative plan
and how that plan came about
the president of the rail trail can tell
you I think frankly
to
load a theory and then issue a gag order
on someone
and then use it as part of a bidding
process is unethical
that's the impetus of that mess
and it and as a as a member which I did
not disclose as a member of the board of
directors of dairy's rail trail
I wasn't I never saw this I never
approved this I never agreed to this
because a
an engineering firm issued a gag order
to prevent the discussion of it
well you've certainly raised a lot of
sensitive issues I guess so put it
mildly
so I unless anyone has any further
questions I'd oh I'm sorry
go ahead
thank you Mr chair one more question
uh party of justification is that we
need to keep that right away open in
case we ever decide to put a railroad
there again
how high is the Box tunnel and would the
Box tunnel handle a freight car or
locomotive going through it so the Box
tunnels original design was at 12 feet
the the compromise if you will to lower
the pitch of the Madden Road over the
top of it is at 11 feet if the railroad
decides to go through there will be
substantial modifications to this
railroad bed anyway
in which time they the railroad can
lower the grade the bottom of this thing
they wouldn't have to they wouldn't have
to take it out they could just lower the
floor
um the subsequent tunnels north of there
in Londonderry were all constructed to
Railroad standard
so Londonderry has tunnels on this on
this railroad bed two railroad standard
but some in Windham has railroad
standard tunnels
under a road that does not necessarily
connect to this rail trail but to a
different one
but somehow that's okay for every other
community but not mine
into it to and I feel as though
representative McGuire didn't totally
answer one of your questions and I'll
and I'll do it this way in the sense
that this is a Federal Highway project
so as far as your constituents there's a
lot of constituents I suppose that pay
for a Federal Highway project because
it's it comes out of the federal there's
federal dollars involved and there's
State dollars involved as well so this
is not something that's unique in
Standalone in the sense of the town of
dairy asking for this this is
encompassing a Federal Highway 125
million dollar Federal Highway project
so it's you know when when you're going
to cut a swath through the middle of my
town
I expect that it's done in a way that
doesn't
hurt my constituents is part of the way
they designed this project so
depending on how you want to look at the
dollars it's that's where this
that's how this thing is framed here as
part of a Federal Highway project
um
so you're making it sound as though
the federal government is imposing this
project on your town but your town paid
five million dollars as did the
neighboring town because they want this
project
correct they were and again they were
after they signed that contract changes
have been made
so
as right
that's that's not shocking or new or
anything I mean it's you know Federal
Highway projects all kinds of projects
develop over time but
it's not the same
it's interesting uh following up on
representative Griffin's question
because the widening of 93 to the north
through Londonderry they built a highway
bridge over the rail trail a significant
Crossing with a bridge
so anyway well we'll get you off the
hook for a little while and maybe
someone else would like to come oh I'm
sorry representative Ebel has a question
not a problem
um well I have the article also when
they talked about the decision by the
council I guess not to recommend I'm
looking at and so they were concerned
about the expenses but I'm referring
back to the quote that representative
McGuire read and if you continue through
not only were they the council members
concerned about the expenses they were
also concerned about the delay aspect so
I wondered if you could comment on that
because obviously to make this change
would also cause a delay so the delay
the the parameters of that delay are up
for significant debate here the
Department of Transportation has been
well aware of the objections of
stakeholder groups for this going almost
on two years now
the VHB whose symbol is on the bottom of
this page provided a design for that
tunnel several years ago
so what I was told by the project
manager was it's about slope and
drainage issues
this doesn't go out to bid until October
at the earliest
we have engineers at the D.O.T
that can do what needs to be done here
this this shouldn't take till October to
do
for to design slope and drain issues
around a an element that was in the
original design to start with so I I I
question that I questioned the the
length to which they claim a delay would
occur here
for when they still have a hundred
properties to acquire
that still have not been acquired to do
this this phase of the project
when the dot itself has delayed this
project dozens of times since 1982.
and they've been aware of the objections
to this for two years who's really where
are the delays really coming from here
it's not it's not from the rail trail
further question
I just want to be clear uh you're
basically asserting that the design
that's being proposed by dot at this
point is not safe as a safety
professional for 27 years and someone
with an engineering degree in the
practice I will tell you there are two
elements that are definitely not safe
about this
and that predominantly has to do with
the way that the rail trail
has line of sight coming down from the
Londonderry end under that bridge and as
someone who predominantly rides a
bicycle on those with a five degree
slope on that end
we're going to have collisions
at that point where that where that
makes the turn under the bridge it's you
just can't see you don't know who's
under the bridge when you're coming down
that
down that hill and
that that's not a matter of if it's
going to happen so I I don't want to see
that ever happen I don't want to see
anybody ever get wiped out here and the
design of this by itself lends to that
not only does it is that my opinion but
we have through a 91a request internal
documents that I would hope one of the
people behind me has from internally
within the dot they have questioned the
safety of this
so safety is a huge Factor safety is
also a huge factor in federal approval
which this doesn't have so
you know I this really needs I'm hoping
the federal the federal folks that are
responsible for approving this take a
real hard look at the safety aspect of
this because I have real concerns on the
way that they've they've done this
all right thank you thank you Mr chair
representative of your town for sure
um
now sir I I assume that you would like
to speak
and if you could state your name and
spell your last name if it's difficult
please
it's Connors it's an Irish name I think
as long as you get the O in the end
instead of the E you're good
so I'm going to pass around some
handouts as well unfortunately my color
printer ran out of ink because I did
these at home last night so some of you
are getting colors I mean you're getting
black and white and you can look at each
other as if we get to a color point so
uh
I don't have the resources of the dot to
do the Big Color Prints and all that I
was prepared to show you guys a
PowerPoint though because I work in
sales and I thought you might have some
projection equipment so this is done on
a PowerPoint I apologize also for the
size thought we might be looking at this
on a projector
um so uh first of all uh thank you uh
chairman and members of this committee
for uh having us and allowing us to
testify especially given the uh the the
uh that we uh some of us missed last
week we thought this was the reschedule
not not a committee meeting so it would
have been nice to speak to the larger
group as well
um my name is Mark Connors I am the
President of the Derry rail trail
Alliance I'm also a member of the
Granite State uh rail trail those are
two volunteer positions uh that take a
lot of my time in addition to my job in
selling software to large universities
non-profits and hospitals I've been a
member of the board of the dairy realtor
Alliance since 2007 I moved to Derry in
2004. uh the reason I got involved in
this at all was I had small children at
that time and took them for a ride on
the Windham rail trail and you'll hear
from the president of the Windham rail
trail in a little bit they had a
beautifully new paved rail trail
including a wonderful bridge over the
new Route 111 that had been blasted
through at that time which you'll see
some photos of that in my deck so the
whole idea of a rail trail coming into
dairy uh jumped up there was a gentleman
named Eric Whitney who started the dairy
rail trail Alliance I joined with him
and we quickly formed a non-profit
organization and said we have to do what
Windham has done and extend this up to
Derry and through Derry on to
Londonderry
so that's how I got involved in this and
I've been there ever since now the first
trip I ever took on the rail trail my
kids were on single speed bikes they
were five six they are now graduated and
out of college and I'm still trying to
get this rail trail done in Derry
we had the first sections going from
downtown Dairy all the way down to
Windham Dunn in a matter of a couple of
years because we were able to raise the
money work with the town of Derry we had
a great partnership the the citizens
stood up and we got those those uh that
version done since then we have been at
loggerheads and getting to Londonderry
because of the exit 4A project in the
continuous delays so we have been
patient we have been working with the
DIA with the dot with our town DPW
trying to get everything aligned for the
rail trail to go north and connect to
Londonderry Londonderry also has four
miles of paved trail now leading to the
airport and it is now connecting into
Manchester and very soon the entire
Granite State rail trail hopefully in
the next few years will span from the
Massachusetts Border in Salem all the
way to Lebanon in the Vermont border
there are over 50 miles of the rail
trail already complete from Lebanon
South to just north of Concord the state
you guys have just appropriated some new
purchases and things within Concord to
get your rail trail here in Concord and
that is going to connect
so anyway iob signed up for the rail
trail is just a volunteer thinking yeah
we'll get this thing done
when exit 4A started to become an issue
with how we were going to get the rail
trail through there when we realized the
exit 4A Connector Road was going to
bisect the rail trail and basically cut
it off we started to get a little bit
involved in politics and working with
the dhdot I signed up as a Consulting
partner on the exit 4A project in order
to be informed of everything that the
dot designed by their own rules I'm
supposed to get all their documents I'm
supposed to get all their information in
order to make sure that we were
represented
that's been a little bit touch and go
um as to how that actually has taken so
anyway this has been a long and winding
road to this point and it's looks like
you know the map in front of you at this
point with as many curves as the new
drta plan
simply stated if you you put that map
you take all the stuff off of the maps
that they're in front of you and you put
this in front of a third grader and say
you got to go from point A to point B
which way are you going to go
100 percent of the people are going to
go across the rail trail straight a rail
trail by Design if you look up a you
know a rail trail is supposed to follow
an old rail Corridor it's supposed to be
flat there's this is not a rail trail
one anymore once D.O.T puts this in this
is no longer a rail trail by Design and
they've even referred to it as a nice
local recreational path and so on and so
forth no this is part of the alternative
transportation Corridor which has
actually been required of the dot since
the beginning of I-93 in the first
several pages that I've included in the
document come from the Rizzo study from
back in 2003 and again I apologize for
the smaller type that you see there but
these documents are still available out
on dot Zone page and I encourage you to
go out and actually read the documents
there so in order to get the approval
for I-93 widening the dot had to include
an alternative transportation plan and
Corridor and so they spent a lot of
money on this study which which is you
know very detailed and they hired groups
and so on and so forth and their own
plan calls for this alternative
transportation Corridor if you read
through the documents it identifies the
m l Branch the Manchester to Lawrence
branch of the rail trail as the most
inexpensive the right alternative they
were also thinking of running a rail
trail up the middle of 93 or something
as well so they actually designed and
came up with the idea of this rail trail
the problem was they never funded it
unfortunately dot in New Hampshire is
really focused on automobile
Transportation versus alternative
transportation that really is at the
root of some of this problem we need
transportation of all types so if you
read the own report that went back to
2003 that the dot spent a lot of money
on UNH and everybody else was involved
and have highlighted a few names on the
people who are involved in that you'll
notice one of the names is William Cass
our current commissioner of the D.O.T
was on this original study plan as was
Mr Mark samsel who's sitting in the back
of the room who'll talk to you from
Windham rail trail in a little while and
several other folks were involved from
the community related to bicycling and
alternative transportation and rail
trails and they came up with this whole
plan and one of the things that call
that I call out on this page is that the
reason they called it out is because it
has a flat less than two percent grade
if you read some of the other details
that is accessible to all people
including disability disabled people
people in wheelchairs Walkers elderly
which is a huge part of the people that
you will see on our Dairy rail trail
every day people rehabilitating injuries
heart attacks Walkers it it's a
wonderful mix of people parents with
strollers so on and so forth and that's
the idea behind a rail trail is to
create Community it also is the lowest
cost alternative that was come up by the
dot now again this was 2003 the entire
4A project at that point was supposed to
cost 50 million dollars as I hope you
all know we're over 130 million dollars
now to get that same project done
because of the delays
so just looking at that it was ranked
highest because of accessibility natural
resources compatibility with the
neighborhoods connectivity to the cities
and links to our commuter centers so you
all know about the exit 5 Transportation
Center the dot and the state has spent a
huge amount of money on one at exit two
one at exit three
well let me tell you something a few
years ago to prove that alternative
transportation is real I rode my bike
to work
I live in Derry New Hampshire I worked
in Peabody Massachusetts at the time I
rode my bike on the rail trail up to
londonderry's Transportation Center I
got on the bus with my bike I went down
to sell station got off my bike got off
the you know bus at South Station rode
my bike across Boston to North Station
got on a train to Lynn get off the train
and land and rode my bike to Peabody it
can be done I'm probably foolish for
doing it but I was trying to prove a
point so yeah too long about three hours
it was a long commute won't do it again
um but just to point out it is this is
supposed to be an alternate
Transportation you'll also see on the
document for the Rizzo study that this
talks about the fact that there will be
public hearings input involvement of the
community as dot designs this
alternative and that is where a major
failure has happened unfortunately in
what is in front of you today
this is one of my first times getting
involved in Dot and all that and like I
said we had a pretty good partnership I
thought
um but D.O.T kind of just went off the
rails and decided to go do their own
thing without involving us and I used
that you know term on purpose
um they just kind of came up with this
alternative and and and I will I will
touch on that and then without enough
public input they decided that was the
way they were going and it all of a
sudden showed up at a here at a public
meeting as the only option
so the other slides that I've included
someone mentioned those bridges at Exit
five in Londonderry this is the ml
Corridor so when dot says well we're not
really planning on trains coming back on
this Corridor therefore we don't need to
worry about keeping the corridor open
well why the heck excuse me did we spend
tens of millions of dollars on four
train size overpasses for this little
paved path to go under there then
that's what we did tens of millions of
dollars for those four bridges in
Londonderry in Windham when they blasted
the new 111 the pictures you have there
are showing when we put in that new 111
that didn't even exist that road just
became you know a brand new road they
had to keep the rail corridor open
because our laws say you have to keep
these quarters open for future rail
potential the likelihood of rail coming
back does not matter on this particular
line may not happen but we are supposed
to be doing that especially when
representative Pearson mentions a line
was used after I believe 1964 as live
rail it has to be maintained by our own
laws putting this highway in and and
they knew this in Derry too because when
they um when they did take out the
bridges that Mr uh Pearson mentioned
there was a bridge at Folsom Road an old
one old rickety wooden bridge like you
see in different places
they actually put in a six foot metal
tunnel Culvert you can barely walk
through it without whacking your head on
it or anything but they did that because
they were required to keep the
connectivity of that rail Corridor they
could not just fill it in and put a road
across it we have the same thing at
Bowers Road where another Bridge was
replaced they had to put a culvert in
there in the 80s in order to comply with
the law so for them to just blast this
and cover up the rail bed now is not
Kosher you have laws against it and you
guys can go and find them we can point
them out to you I'll also say that you
know the dot keeps pointing to this
being a financial question
well I just showed you how much money we
spent in Windham how much money we spent
in Londonderry on the same Trail well
here's another Butte 93 if you go to
mile marker 8.6 get out of your car and
walk off the side of the road the dot
spent Millions to put a box Culvert
under both sides of 93 just about three
years ago
you know for what a rail trail that
doesn't exist a future rail trail that
because there's a rail bed there they
had to keep it open they had to put the
turret tunnel in and they did so this
tunnel exists and probably two or three
people a week use it to walk through
because they live on one side of the 93
or the other Millions for that tunnel
but now we are here because of a 750 000
difference between building this crazy
alternative that sends people down a
five percent grade under a bridge 90
degree turn cross two driveways across
the street and on a downhill slope so I
hearken back to when I took my little
kids for the first ride on their rail
trail why did I love it
they could just ride and I didn't have
to worry about them they could get up
100 feet ahead of me there was no
Crossings there was nothing you got a
kid on a little bike with a mom pushing
a stroller with the other kid and the
little kid starts getting going down
that Hill he's going across two people's
driveway who are backing out and he's
got to come to that furlin street go
across the street take a 90 degree turn
go down another slope that's just under
Ada at just under five percent do 180
degree buttonhook Loop come back down a
slope to the stream level and then shoot
under a bridge as Mr Pearson said where
there's people coming at 18 to 20 miles
an hour the other way in darkness or
under a bridge maybe it's not dark but
under a bridge this is accidents waiting
to happen the dairy fire department is
going to be spending they might as well
just post a truck out there if this
thing goes through
so someone asked I think it was Rhett
McGuire finances why is this in front of
the finance committee quite honestly I
wish this never got in front of our Town
Council and they never had to take the
vote I personally as a consultant on
this project the drta the New Hampshire
rails Trails Coalition the granite state
rail Trails bike walk Alliance in New
Hampshire has been pleading with DOT
to work with them to come up with a
solution we've been shut out
they won't do it we've heard and again
anecdotally I hope you guys can look
into it that the Dot's own safety
department has not been allowed to look
at or comment publicly on this plan
they hadn't even seen it
someone mentioned National resource
natural resources the ml Corridor is a
historic corridor so forget all the rail
trail stuff even if this wasn't an
active rail after 1964 it's a historic
quarter that also has to be kept intact
and in fact the approval for I-93 and
the exit 4A got credits from the federal
government and positive upticks in order
for them to even do this whole 93
widening and exit 4A project because
of what they put in the plan because
they said we're going to build a
beautiful rail trail and we're actually
going to build these Wing walls that are
going to have a historic representation
of what the rail used to look like and
so they sold this thing to natural
resources and the New Hampshire
historical preservation Society those
folks also haven't said okay to this
plan yet that's one of the reasons it
hasn't gone to the feds is they still
haven't got the approval of those people
because they say wait wait a minute you
said you were keeping the corridor open
so please do your homework on this thing
now Finance let's get to the money
because I don't want to keep you guys
all day I could talk about this for
months so dot also uh did a study I
think it came out this August or past
August August 2022 and again this
picture of it but you guys can go online
and you can see the whole thing
commissioned by the D.O.T again spent a
bunch of money on this
over 18 million dollars annually is
coming to New Hampshire because of the
rail trails
7.5 million of that is coming from the
Derry Windham Londonderry sections of
the existing Trail 7.5 million
and we're talking we're cobbling over
750 000 tunnel on a 130 million dollar
project after they've spent Millions on
all these other tunnels this makes no
sense to me quite honestly for a while I
figured there had to be something going
on behind the scenes someone wasn't
telling us the whole deal someone had
their finger in the pie something not
Kosher was going on Dot's proven to us
that no that's not the case there's no
backroom deals there's nothing we just
don't want to spend 750 000 for the
safest best alternative in Dairy that's
what they've said that's their only
argument
so again just pointing to their own
report Senate Bill 185 adopted in 2019
is an act to develop New Hampshire State
rail trails and in that act it actually
talks about the preservation of
important investment corridors again so
they were thinking about rail Trails
we're not anti-rail some people said oh
you know what they should be doing is
bringing back the trains absolutely if
you can bring back a train most people
on rail Trails don't have a problem we
can do rail with Trail we're not against
the trains coming back in fact when
Woodmont Commons uh which is the big
exit 4A project up there when they did
their charrettes 10 years ago I was
there I went over to the apple orchard
and sat in their building you know what
was planned just north of this tunnel a
train station because they were doing a
multimodal approach and again when they
sold their product project there was
gonna be a train coming up here so
people could commute from Woodmont to
Boston and there was a beautiful train
station planned we've been working with
Woodmont and there folks all along too
in fact Woodmont owns some of the rail
beds someone asked about the ownership
of the rail bed not Woodmont but people
involved in the project own part of the
rail bed they've already agreed to turn
it over to Derry and Londonderry in
order for the rail trail to be built
once exit 4A is complete everybody is on
board this rail trail is gold so the
other thing that I'll point to is the
economic impact study within that New
Hampshire rail Trails Coalition report
is again dot numbers they did it so
almost 19 million raised 7.5 uh I think
eight of it or was it four of it is
coming from tourism I will tell you
personally we this Trail is on the
international
bike path uh
plan I've had people from Germany Sweden
England Canada
stay in my house because I've run into
them riding on the rail trail with their
fully loaded bikes and they're like hey
where do we stay where can we camp where
are the hostels on this Trail we don't
have any yet but come on stay with me so
this Trail is bringing people from all
around the world other states if you go
to Wisconsin look at Wisconsin you look
at Maryland there's the Cumberland
Maryland trail that goes from Pittsburgh
into Maryland 100 million dollars or
more in Revenue every year attributed to
that 100 Mile Trail that is the vision
for New Hampshire that is what we are
trying to build is this Granite State
rail trail we've only got the gap
between Concord and Manchester left once
we get this debacle with 4A squared away
because we have one mile to pave between
us and Londonderry we're ready to do
that as soon as this tunnel is done and
then you've got a trail that runs from
Massachusetts all the way to Manchester
already paved so we're going to need
your help a little bit more than just
this I'm I'm hoping that you folks are
getting educated on the whole rail trail
and Granite State rail trail concept too
because
I would love for this to move forward
get this Tunnel built it's a no-brainer
as I say in my final slides this should
never have gotten this far it's a waste
of people's time 750
000 is an investment I would say for one
child's life who might get hit by a car
on that crazy alternative
I would also ask we've been asking the
question how much is dot spent for the
last two and a half years developing and
redeveloping and coming to these
meetings and going to the public with
this crazy alternative I bet you it
already pays for the tunnel if you guys
could get those numbers out of D.O.T
we'd appreciate it because they won't
give them to us
so not not to uh I appreciate it I'm
gonna I'm gonna wrap up with that I'm
gonna ask you guys to build the tunnel
excuse me and ask any questions you want
are there any questions uh
because I'm sure we'll have a few more
with I'd like to uh if there are no
questions I'd like to have a
representative from the dot come up
because we've heard some thank you
pretty interesting testimony and there's
a lot of interesting things that I've
been reading up here as well so I'd like
to get your comment
and where things stand
and if you could introduce yourself and
spell your last name sure Peter stamness
director of project development for DOT
uh s t as in Thomas A M N A S as in Sam
um
good afternoon
Mr chairman director of project
development
oh we see the highway and Bridge
programs across the state
projects through the 10-year plan
foreign
trying to figure out where where to
start
um from a from a from a presentation
standpoint
um
I think I'd like to start initially
um by
um clarifying A few
um things that were said about the
project in general
um and then maybe I can go into
um I think they explain the the details
of the of the uh various options
um you know I don't know that we need to
go through that but but at least like to
to clarify some of the things that I
think May
um
may have been misstated in some way so
the 4A project
this project is a is it was a is a town
of Londonderry and dairy project
so it had been from the beginning back
in 2014 the contract that you heard
about that was signed uh because there
was difficulty by the municipalities to
get this project delivered
so the dot said that um we'll we'll
deliver this project we're going to
finish the design we're going to engage
Consultants to complete the work and
um we've captured your financial
participation in this set the five
million dollars that was for each town
so it's a town project this is this this
wasn't
a DOT project it was a town initiated
project they had Advanced it through a
public hearing
um you know back in early 2000s and it
sat for a while because it because of
everything else that was going on at the
time
so
um so I don't know if that's helpful for
you but
um this is this the dot is finishing the
project for the municipalities of dairy
in Londonderry
representative Hatchet any of you that
have a question during his presentation
feel free to wave at me and we'll take
the question
um just for the characterization of what
this project is but it's also a uh isn't
it an important link to the overall
project as to what was spoken to
previously in other words I don't think
it would be a correct
characteristicization to say that this
is just a two-ton project in very
isolated it's part of a very important
link
um throughout or not please clear that
up yeah I didn't mean to
um intimate that I I I was mainly
um you know the the commentary about the
the constant delays by the dot
um from the beginning it no it's it's an
important project it provides a
um you know it's a a improves the
economic development through the area it
also provides some traffic relief for
exit four and and connections to 102 to
the West so there's there's this value
here
um and I didn't mean to uh
um make a statement that would suggest
otherwise
so I have a follow-up to uh
representative hatch
you just said each Town provided five
million dollars is that correct that's
the first time I've heard it's like 10
10 million dollars now it's not just the
5 million that Dairy provided
now they contracted with the state DOT
because the contract was referenced in
the early earlier discussion so
both Londonderry and dairy signed a
contract with a D.O.T to design and
carry this project through it's a
municipal agreement that we laid out
um conditions
um who would pay what who would be you
know making decisions how we would
coordinate decision making throughout
the project and and it laid out the was
the groundwork for bringing the project
to completion
and we can get a copy of that contract
I'm sure it's available certainly
certainly
representative evil
thank you uh Mr chair so just so that we
don't lose track of it I mean I come
from a 10 years on public works and
highways committee and there we have a
10-year plan that we work on every
biennium and so I have to assume that
this is all part of many many working
pieces that are continuing for foray
which has been a project that's been
going on for a long time so
how does this fit into the 10-year plan
process
and so from a from a from a from a
quarter project standpoint or this box
covert uh discussion just from the
I guess what I'm trying to say is that
there's a huge planning process that's
been going on with relationship to 93
and you've obviously thought about a lot
of these working pieces and this is one
of many that you've had to fit into
a long-range developing puzzle
correct statement yes
um from a so this comes up
um every two years when we update the
the 10-year plan
um
this project for a while had not
been funded and it it got funded
um through the 10-year plan and that's
that's our that's our long-range plan uh
from a from a transportation it's our
work plan it you know we travel around
the state
um generally
um 20 to 25 hearings talking about
important projects in in um
um
each region
um it's overseen by the executive
Council
and it receives significant amount of
Public public input overall so this
project and all the projects that are
within the 10-year plan receive
tremendous amount of public input
typically not down to the the details
about box culverts but just in general
the value of the project the
um the purpose of the project and and
and what the outcomes
um would be
um
when the project is completed
thank you so so it's just
in some ways it's hard to view it in
isolation because it's part of a whole
package that you're working on sure
thank you
so I have one question uh kind of a
follow-up to the whole funding scenario
now each time put the five million
dollars and in this Connector Road where
there are federal funds put in for that
state funds local funds
well obviously that this whole project
is a lot more than 10 million dollars so
what this whole redesigned you know the
cost of that redesign and carry through
as far as the completion of the project
so that it's
um the construction cost estimate
currently is around 104 million dollars
and it's all it's federally funded so
this is a this is federally funds there
are no uh State funds involved we don't
have a lot of State funds for
transportation projects in the state of
New Hampshire so this is a federally
funded project and the town's
contribution the five million dollar
each
um was
um you know part of part of the deal
again it was it was a municipal project
to begin with
um and I'm sure that there are probably
uh hours and hours of information that
could be shared with you not by me at
how that how that came about the five
million dollar
um like I can't go there I'm sure
there's there's there were lots of
discussions about that and probably a
few lawyers involved
when you say part of the deal
is that the deal to put in this
underpass tunnel
or I'm looking at this plan that we were
just given it's a little clear to look
at or this I hate to use the word but
since it was used already the spaghetti
plan who came up with a spaghetti plant
was that in the original
contract they have a route that was
somewhat removed from the existing real
Corridor or
um so the contract that you speak of the
agreement
I don't believe made any mention of of
the rail trail it was specific to the
delivery of the project and the costs
associated with that who was going to
prosecute the design who was a decision
maker how is that going to be
communicated
um and I would
um
I don't believe the the decision to put
a to put a a tunnel in was done prior to
that contract that that that agreement
we knew that the the trail
um the the railroad Corridor
um that the road that we that that was
planned to be constructed was going to
bypass was going to was going to
intersect that rail quarter and we had
to figure out a way
um to accommodate that that uh Corridor
um
so you know was it going to be an at
Great Crossing was it going to be a
tunnel was it going to be some other
grade separated
um um Crossing you know that wasn't part
that wasn't that wasn't really included
in the early in the early designs I I
would expect that there was probably
some level of discussion about
um you know working towards a grade
separated solution which both of these
alternatives are they're both great
separated solutions they both have five
percent grades
um from the rail from the from from
where the trail meets the the uh the uh
the railroad Corridor to get it under to
get it under Folsom Road both options
have five percent down and five percent
up one's just a little bit longer than
the other one
so I'm a little puzzled because
I'm actually in the railroad business so
maybe I've got a disadvantage but
um it's
you say there's a five percent grade to
take it under the road but somebody
testified earlier I believe that there
was a bridge there before that went over
the rail grade so the real grade would
not have a grade of five percent it just
doesn't work that way that's correct
so the so Folsom Road and we're getting
into
um I was told to keep this simple but
this is really simple stuff Folsom road
is is is probably eight to ten feet
higher than the than the than the than
the uh Railroad
Corridor the the railroad bed
okay well
um I do have a question representative
McGuire had to leave and he said please
ask the dot about the contract he States
here are we opening ourselves up to a
lawsuit by Dairy to enforce the
provisions of the contract with the
tunnel plan so that's a question from
representative McGuire
can you repeat the question again I I
sure
are we opening up to a lawsuit by the
town of dairy to enforce the provisions
of the contract with the tunnel plan I I
don't think that the tunnel was included
in the in the in the agreement that I'm
talking about I I could be mistaken but
I don't believe it is
all right well he had that question so
I'll ask but I'll let you continue
unless there are any further questions
and I'd like to caution everybody we're
already
45 minutes behind on our next hearing we
didn't anticipate this would become so
involved to be honest with you
I also have
[Music]
um
poppies of the
correspondence just to give
um for and I'd like to pass out copies
of the correspondence between a sample
of the correspondence between the dot
and
um
uh the town I'm going to keep one of
these
he's about to pass a letter that wasn't
sent to the dot it was sent to a private
contractor while I was under a
non-exclosure agreement that's the
letter he's going to pass you out and I
have a problem I've never been released
from the NBA they aren't even supposed
to have it went to a private company
we
have to be oh it was an objection
raised and just out on the climates
stop it I'm just just one minute
the letter I passed out to the normal
letter that sent from the brca
um
all right
um let's see
um
there was mention of of uh the crosswalk
and the direct route
um between
um
that that people wouldn't use the
the trail under the river bridge the the
alternative concept uh the crosswalk the
surface Crossing at Folsom Road
um
would be there if we didn't have a rail
trail Crossing it's it's necessary for
the sidewalks at uh to connect the
sidewalk from the north side of Folsom
road to south side of Folsom road so
whatever option
um whatever option is chosen whatever
option is constructed the crosswalk
across Folsom Road will be there it's
it's not it's not subject to
um uh you know a decision of one one
um one option or the other
um
you know
the delays
um the
we put our pencils down
um a while back as we got into uh
additional discussions
um over
um the Alternatives
um we've we've encountered some delays
um if if we
um change course again there'll be more
delays
um this is not this design is not being
completed by
um the dot it's being completed by
Consultants hired by the dot to
prosecute the design it would require
change orders and it will require delays
and overall delivery of the project
that's just the fact so for someone to
suggest otherwise is just incorrect
um
I hate to put you on the spot but I
can't resist I guess I'm taking a page
out of the uh chairman Weiler Playbook
on this because I I'm looking at again
the proposed plan
that shows a five percent grade the the
alternative
route that circles around and again I
hate to use it again spaghetti plant as
it's been referred to
and to me looking at that doesn't make
any sense
it just doesn't
when you have an existing real Corridor
that used to connect Manchester with
Lawrence
in putting some kind of whether it's a
bridge or a tunnel or something
in that existing railroad grade why
anyone would propose
something that I see to the right this
trail that goes around and across
private driveways and across a very busy
street it just I'm having a hard time
getting my head around that
so
yes
representative Griffin I'm along with
that vein of thinking earlier one of the
speakers
said that the Department of
Transportation had never had the safety
people look at the alternative plan I
wonder if you'd like to comment on that
yeah that the plan as proposed has been
reviewed
um it it meets ADA compliance there were
some reviews that were done
um on the earlier alignments that
required modification
um and it was was mentioned earlier that
you know we did a review and we didn't
like what we saw and so we asked them to
modify it to provide more sight distance
to make improvements to a preliminary
concept alignment
um basically that could prove that we we
could meet the grades necessary
to uh have the trail go under the bridge
Shields Brook bridge
and it could be accommodated as with
anything as we advance designs we
fine-tune the design to make sure that
it meets safety requirements and ADA
requirements and there might be other
things that will be modified before the
project gets bid out that's that's the
way this this works
um and um
so so we believe it's a safe design and
and
um we wouldn't put it out if we didn't
think it didn't wasn't safe
I'm sorry
um not to cut you short but there were a
number of people that I think that have
traveled from
far away perhaps
um
and I'd like to get on to our next year
we'll be holding another work session on
this bill is obviously we've been given
a lot of information to digest and look
at a lot of questions have been brought
up but
any of you folks again recognizing that
we will be holding another work session
on this uh if you have like five minutes
you'd like to offer and the gentleman in
the back uh yes I'm concern so so I'm
done yeah well we'll we'll schedule
another work session we're over an hour
into the next work session so to be fair
to the people that are waiting for that
so we'll be in touch
okay
and if you could please state your name
for the record and please try to be
brief if you can definitely thank you Mr
chairman name here is Dave topam from
Salem there's a little background of
myself while I'm here today and
oh Topham
t-o-p-h-a-m like ham sandwich okay
I'm here today uh representing the
organization called New Hampshire rail
Trails Coalition but a little
professional background on me why I have
a real serious interest in this entire
project
I'm a certified bicycling instructor
I have been working with DOT as
volunteer for over 40 years there hasn't
been a single project Mike ped related
for maps safety brochures plans
including the design of the Memorial
Bridge connecting Portsmouth to Kittery
that I have not been involved in along
with others not just me alone
and the input from the bicycling
Community for DOT design has been a
major factor in safety all the way
through including on the Memorial Bridge
the Belvedere is the bump outs that came
from us in the bicycling Community
talking with Dot and the design phase
early on so again I just want to fast
forward that I've been involved with a
lot of things the dot for many years
including the charter member what's
known as the complete streets advisory
committee with Sarah's at the pleasure
of the commissioner okay this is not
federally a state mandated this is
within Dot
I was appalled when I heard and learned
October 28th of 21.
that this tolerable plan that we had
seen repeatedly throughout 2019 a
10-year plan the gasset hearings as Mr
Stamos said that goes around the state
does some 20 yard meetings the asset
plans are put forward look at a 10-year
plan we were shown hey guys we're
putting a tunnel under the new 4A
connector room it's there it's in print
we saw that
congratulations we didn't know until
October 28th
of 21.
mysteriously the tunnel is going on
how'd that happen
that was so it's too late now it's out
of the planning stage it's in design
it's 25 design completed when we first
heard about it what happened to public
hearing oh there was a meeting between
Dot and a few folks in Derry behind a
closed door with the muzzle on
confidentiality cause they couldn't talk
about it and I'm on the same board as my
partners
okay what is wrong with the spiritual
so I went up wearing my safety hat
I went back to complete streets advisory
committee basically the chair of it
bicycle safety group within the Bureau
of Highway design
and if I mentioned names right now but
believe I know very well you know the
building was after 40 years
set 30 feet away from project manager
same Bureau I said how could this happen
this is totally unsafe I mean a
three-year-old the kids who showed up in
the Derry Town Council meetings they're
saying the same thing they're in
wheelchairs how can we do all this this
doesn't make any sense so I went to the
bike safety group
we were not consulted
February of 21 I conducted a zoom
meeting with DOT including the project
manager was there why we don't talk to
each other
we work in silos we worked at Value
engineering we are saving money
what happened to the safety
we're not talking about it I want to put
it on the agenda for d.o.t's own
complete streets advisor committee
as a child member on that committee
it was refused we cannot talk about it
you cannot talk about it dot won't allow
me to talk about it publicly in a
recorded session with a subset
Engineering Group D.O.T shut me down you
cannot talk about it
what is going on
so bottom line
just a point and again I value your time
I don't want to Ramble On I've been too
involved with this for so long I could
really help on for an hour I won't but
just take the basic concept if you have
a 10 12 foot wide this is a 10 foot plan
here but lady let us 12 feet wide if you
have a thousand to 1500 people a day on
all modes and we're talking about the
overall concept that dot uses contact
sensitive Solutions
designed for the plant designed for what
you built to build it for
a lot of emphasis I give Dot credit Pitt
standards the widening of I-93 projects
well I went all the way back to the I-93
trans investment study I was on that
committee too
it's great
but when it comes to the bicycle
infrastructure and support for it very
very weak and honestly there was no one
either Consultants or within dot or the
bike pay Community or Federal Highway
who have yet to this day had input for
the safety aspects of this quote
spaghetti crew none
and that can be confirmed with multiple
people so again I appreciate your
consideration the funding aspects allows
you to slow in for the funding very
quickly it's interesting to notice that
project section A that's the major
connector to 93 that's under
construction now just go by today coming
up from Salem
that at a four million dollar overrun
it was paid for mysteriously four
million dollars came about to the
overage in the first 48 Hours here we
are talking about 750
000 for the cost differential between
the current plan which is totally unsafe
and having the tunnel 750 000 on about
104 110 million dollar project
doesn't make sense against 80 Federal 20
New Hampshire toll credits is what's
finding it Gary was not asked to do
anything in one quick term that ladder
that came down which we have a copy of
from commissioner Bill cast it was
December 14th 16th there were both
saying that Dairy is going to be on the
hook not only for the cost of the title
but to rework the plans and because of
the delays that's got to extrapolate
into maybe two to six million dollars of
Larry taxpayers say no no can't go there
I questioned that writing final point on
again I have to get off the bandwagon
here I know but still very quickly when
it comes to the delays we're very
concerned about delays and I don't know
your meeting
yeah
yeah but
fair enough anyway just for the delays
we have not only the delays for the
reworking of the redesigned plans
preliminary design engineering has now
done 65 percent estimated to change the
plans now as Vanessa May might take six
to eight months
what hasn't been stated is what is the
delay to get the new federal approvals
the environmental impact statements
Environmental Protection groups the
flood plain Army Corps of Engineers all
these people have to weigh in yet that
approval process takes months
and that is what mainly that five
million dollars from the area of
Londonderry if you look at that contract
that was for the Environmental Studies
primarily it wasn't for the construction
it was studying the overall projects
so take a look at the numbers see where
we are and again
I feel honestly D.O.T and the state
shouldn't have to pick up any part of
the funding for this if needed yes if
not let's see where that 4 million came
from immediately that went into advanced
section A of section
130565 1365 a
thank you
thank you very much any questions
seeing none of the representative in the
back would you like to
okay thank you thank you for your time
well sure
quickly handles from distributionally
yeah if you want to just hand them to Mr
Hoffman there he'll make sure we get a
copy
good afternoon good afternoon for your
patience if you could state your name my
name is Catherine prudholm O'Brien I'm a
state representative from Derry I have a
lot to say on this I have been walking
those Trails for 30 years I walked them
often my husband is a disabled veteran
and when he had spinal fusion surgery
walking on the trails was a big part of
his recovery
when I recently joined my friend with
the uh with unrecumbent bikes with the
VA uh associate I'm sorry the Veterans
Administration uh
um Therapy Program
they would not they they would not be
able to use the trail
with this spaghettified design and
they were very concerned about grades of
say one or two percent over a mile and
they absolutely wouldn't be able to use
this this would be dangerous this is
dangerous for them it's dangerous for
bicyclists in general it's dangerous for
mothers with strollers
I don't like the spaghettified plan and
I remember the first time I heard about
it it was that same meeting that Mr
Topham just spoke of it was the 10 28 21
meeting at the town uh the municipal
center in Derry and when I first saw
that plan I was aghast I was aghast and
I felt blindsided and I was very
concerned that I had missed something
and I saw it and I said what the heck is
this and I asked the engineer standing
next to the plan what is this
and he told me that was a crossing at
Shield Brook I am familiar with Shield
Brook it's a very small brook and it
floods and at one point people had to be
evacuated in an industrial park near
there because of some flooding issues
I was I couldn't wrap my head around how
they would be putting a crosswalk down
there
I was also told over this whole uh
process of trying to figure out what in
the world happened and how we got here
I was told I should be fighting I should
have been fighting for the straight
passageway a lot sooner and I should
have been going to the 10-year plan and
all those sorts of things in those
meetings I'll tell you something myself
and my community could not wrap our
minds around
having a crossing at Shield Brook that
was something we didn't fight against
because we didn't know we had to fight
against it
we couldn't imagine such a crazy plan
I feel Duty bound to be here and and
express the will of my community if we
put this in if this is put in the
community is going to be furious when
it's done
okay I've spoken to disabled people who
are very busy they work all day they
don't have an opportunity like you and
me and I know we go to a lot of meetings
and we we talk about this stuff at
infant item that's kind of a luxury that
a lot of people don't have
and I have a disabled friend who will
probably be wheelchair bound soon
and she's a guest and she's mad and
she's asking me how did we get here
and all I can tell her is I was
blindsided too and every time I try to
ask questions I am getting nowhere I I
have called
I have lots and lots of notes from every
phone call I make but when I've called
Safety officials at D.O.T nobody seems
to know anything about this they don't
know about it nobody knows Des doesn't
know about it there is a
Beaver damned pond Above This that is
not on your on your
map
that feeds Shield Brook and should that
break suddenly I don't know what's going
to happen nobody has any answers about
that
I am a violent crime Survivor
and I'll tell you something that bend is
kind of scary
I wouldn't want to go down there and
that is a big that's a hill that's a
hill I wouldn't want to go to down to
the bottom of the hill and have a Bend
to go into a bridge
I mean a tunnel that I can't see I can't
see from a long distance that would make
me very nervous I wouldn't use it I live
on the road
I live on I live in Derry but the road
that I live on goes into Windham
and a previous speaker spoke about the
tunnel under Route 93 going under North
and southbound Lanes of Route 93 that
was put in about three years ago and yes
that's true there's very few people that
use it a couple people in in the
neighborhood that walk their dogs
if that could have been built for the
people in the town of Windham why can't
this straight pass-through be built in
Derry
that that tunnel that's in Windham on
that old rail trail leads to Nowhere it
is invisible unless you live in that
neighborhood you don't know where it is
on the side in my neighborhood
I can see it because I know my my street
and I know where it is and I know the
old rail trail crossing that's unpaved
that's in the town of Windham on the
other side of it it goes to a private
daycare business there's no signage and
when you are in when you go to the other
side of it you'd think that this you're
not supposed to be there that this is a
private business and that you're maybe
walking around kids and you're not
supposed to be and making people nervous
you wouldn't go there you would have no
way of knowing that there was a tunnel
there if you were on the other side of
it so that is why nobody uses it what
I'm asking for is a straight Passage
through that thousands of people would
use every week thousands
and I don't think that's too much to ask
for and thank you for your time I know
that this meeting has gone over
thank you for your testimony you're
willing to take any questions if there
are any yes I hope I can answer them and
if not I'm sure we can find someone who
can
any questions hopefully
thank you all right thank you very much
yes sir
if you could try to keep it as brief as
possible again remembering that we'll
have another work session on this bill
next week we haven't pay attention to
the calendar that comes out Friday
thank you very much chairman and
committee members my name is Mark sansel
I'm from Windham I'm the founder of the
Windham rail trail Alliance that we
started our journey back in 2004.
um as well Public Service I uh was the
chairman and served on the zoning board
for 15 years as well on the Rockingham
Planning Commission as well Southern New
Hampshire
hello is this better so it's your
spelling of your last name please oh
samsel
s-a-m-s-e-l I'll respect your time I'm
not sure if I can make it next week so
that that's why I'm asking for a little
bit of time what I like to do is read in
a letter for the record from the Windham
rail trail Alliance and I will just talk
briefly to the economic points uh that
are in the study committee members of
the committee founded in 2004 the
Windham rail trail Alliance is dedicated
to the development and management of
this remarkable 4.6 mile section of
abandoned rail bed uh as a paved rail
trail and this is part of the Granite
State rail trail which we're looking
forward to completing at some point this
section connecting with dairy and Salem
offers 12 miles of continuous paved rail
trail the longest in the state we also
are home to a former b m Caboose the
c-16 so we're happy to provide a nice
recreational asset
2022 is a tremendous year for our rail
counts
um within a 13-day period we recorded
5890 trips
and with a daily average of 453
and that use continues and continued
through that year it was a coveted year
so the numbers were high but right now
the numbers are tremendously high as
well we have a lot of parking issues if
you look to the north of dairy there
counts are 163 000 and that's in 2020.
so if you know logically you can take a
peek and say look at if you look North
look South these numbers are going to be
tremendous in Dairy and there's going to
be a tremendous Economic Development
opportunity for them via the rail trail
we strongly believe that the tunnel is
the appropriate method to keep the
continuity of the trail and the
integrity and the safety I think the
folks that have spoken uh behind me uh
most uh are in favor of that position as
well
and again in Windham we continue uh like
to serve as the benchmark
I'll be happy to answer questions for
you now real quick I want to go through
the 2020 State rail plan and that
there'll be a lot of information I know
Mark mentioned it in the handout that I
have I also have the URL this was
completed in August
that was sponsored and authored by dot
it's 186 Pages
um
I wasn't
um encouraged to make copies for you but
this is the size of the document there's
a lot of detail there which I believe uh
you'll be able to look at it and get a
lot of Snippets and information that's
going to be helpful to you
that rail plan was based on Senate Bill
185 and myself and Bob rimall the
president of the Londonderry Trail
Alliance we worked with Senator Stiles
and Carson on putting that bill together
the committee was led by D.O.T was
authored by Dot and there were five
state agencies representing and also six
Statewide organizations were part of
that committee there were many hearings
publicly held for the input
the statement of purpose and I want to
read this to you and I'll be wrapping
this up this the ACT requires the
development of a plan for the state rail
trail system to ensure preservation and
integrity of these assets into provide
direction for future development
in addition to dividing the role of the
Department of Transportation in
preservation
of rail corridors
the plan will determine the best way to
maximize the return on investment which
is why I'm going through this section
and leverage future investment in
the state rail quarter assets
and we'll determine how to engage towns
cities and private rail trail
organizations in these efforts now I can
say there was reference to it to a
tunnel that was installed under 93 and
that is connected to a town-owned rail
Corridor which was abandoned the state
part of the Western National Nashua and
Portland Trail Town owns it and we're in
the process of developing that and I can
say to the statement of purpose
that that was the you know that was a
Future Vision one of these criteria that
dot is tasked with and that is to look
to the Future
when the widening of 93 occurred that
was the time to do it it was a
cost-effective time to build that tunnel
the scope of the study
uh and when you read that it'll talk to
the inventory economic impact funding
economic and prioritization of State
Investments improving managing and
maintenance
and I did attach uh to you with with you
for you
summary of the counts in summary of the
economic activity
specifically count uh showing you the
activity between Londonderry and Windham
because Dairy smack dab in the middle
derry's numbers are not in here other
than the economic they did combine it
with Windham
that is because the study was only
pointed to state-owned corridors Dairy
is not state-owned it's privately
privately owned
and I talk about the criteria and I
won't go through them those points the
six points you can read them on your own
and I did include the last three pages
are cut and paste of the actual the
economic data that comes from that study
and I'd be willing to be back next week
if my schedule allows it but I'll
entertain any questions that you may
have
well thank you very much for your
testimony if you give a copy of that uh
to Mr hoppin or you have right
okay thank you
all right we'll uh pay attention to next
week's House calendar we'll reschedule
this work session for next week
recess
that being it
we'll see you someday next week
yeah
we'll take a short break a five minute
break
again
foreign
thank you
all right chairman Weiler here we go
so we're at an extreme disadvantage
because I see a number of the sponsors
uh sitting at the table
yeah
Senator Weiler a senator
I just did I just he said that last week
yeah I'm just getting even
representative Weiler anything you'd
like to add or representative evil I see
you your name on the bill
it is badly needed in 1976 they built a
parking garage
and they said it's a 25-year life so in
1992 we bought the building when it was
up for sale from the bank
and in 2005 we hired a
and he's passing out pictures that came
from that
2005 we had a study to and it also
included what was then
and up another lot up for sale across
the street from the police station which
has since been sold and the new
building's gone on it so
the more we delay the worse it gets at
least we're not talking about
taking most of the space and I think
most of the space for the Department of
Justice which the last
um
session we've moved them moved the
Department of Justice to a to another
building about a mile away so
they at the time the parking garage
became an expansion of the Department of
Justice which I didn't think was right
but
they everybody got to the architect the
city of Concord
and the and the bank and everybody
and doj and yet they called it the
parking garage this legislative parking
garage which I was a little bit miffed
at but anyway
I'm delighted to have this bill moving
along and I hope we pass it thank you
any questions for representative Weiler
this uh document that I just handed out
legislative parking garage
representative Weiler actually provided
this to me yesterday so he's been right
on top of this for a couple of decades
per unit
that's not that yeah at all no don't
forget you have to use your mics guys I
representative cameras perfect yes so
I'm just I looked at the front page here
the um
806 to 876 projected spaces who who
would be allowed to use those spaces uh
aside from the legislature
state employees and at the time
they were just going to enlarge doj
which is in this building presently they
were going to Lodge the building 20
percent especially for them
so the doj would have spaces and there
were 15 spaces for the bank which was
considered to still exist and then there
were so many spaces for legislators and
employees of the legislature
and it also included a space across the
street which we could have bought and
didn't someone else has bought it and
put a new building on it so that's even
though you'll see it in the plan it's
not part of the
further question sure thank you Mr chair
uh so would uh would the amount of
spaces available accommodate all the
legislature the Department of Justice
needs
um and any other
uh governmental agencies that may maybe
nearby that need to use it
in that plan yes and it also was
expected to be used when we're not here
which is almost six months of the year
by the city of Concord city of Concord
wanted to be able to have the free use
of it when we weren't needing it
representative evil
thank you very much Mr chair yes I am
also a co-sponsor of this bill I feel
like I've been living the legislative
parking garage not quite as long as
representative Weiler but for quite a
while
um because I was on public works and we
had to keep reassessing the situation
with stores how much money to put into
it I think we've been throwing good
money after bad over there for a really
long time and we really need to move
ahead with this
um so obviously I support it I guess
this bill says it's going to be a
general fund appropriation
my from the facilities committee and
from looking at uh information in the
legislative budget and unfortunately
there's nobody here to talk about it I
mean there are millions of dollars in
the legislative budget
and so I'm wondering why there's not
some con there couldn't be some
contribution where general fund dollars
are short from the legislative budget
so that was a question actually I was
going to ask a little bit more about
what we have in the legislative budget I
mean
I don't want it uh over State the case I
thought it was something like 10 million
dollars we have probably closer to two
or three oh okay well then I overstated
but you know you're right we have been
carrying surpluses from year to year in
the legislative budget not everybody
gets to see it the fiscal committee
quite often gets it put in front of us
at our deliberations on a regular basis
but we usually carry a surplus from year
to year a lot of it went for these front
steps recently but finally there's a
little more in it now so yes we could
possibly say 2 million is coming from
the house side I know the Senate
wouldn't approve it because they already
have all the spaces yeah well I mean it
maybe we could just
um look a little bit more closely at the
legislative budget and see what we think
is a is a appropriate amount there and
then the only other thing I would say is
that coming from a public works
background again when they're a capital
projects of this sort there is some sort
of
oversight from the capital budget
overview committee I mean they sort of
check in
um on the project on its design progress
just to see and and I wasn't sure in a
bill that's a capital project that's
coming through the finance committee
what sort of oversight there was going
to be for a big project like this so
that was another question and honestly I
don't I don't know the process here so I
don't know when to really discuss these
things and then the last thing I would
say is I you know Das is in here I'm not
exactly clear on the interface between
Das and the management of a project of
this magnitude and and the and the
legislature I know we have the
facilities committee
as well
but this is a very large amount of money
so those are my thoughts and maybe
that's the type of thing that if we make
a recommendation here that can be talked
more about at the finance committee at
the full committee level I I just don't
know
yeah I was hoping to have commissioner
arlinghaus here
um and Terry path but maybe they were
here earlier they could have answered
some of your questions but
you're certainly
um
allowed to submit an amendment to us
once we find out what's in the
legislative account Terry pav could have
told us that right off the top of his
head we can also include some a
recommendation of oversight whether it's
whoever you suggest
because what we do here
is make a recommendation of the full
committee through an amendment process
so if you wanted to add two million
dollars say to
this and reduce it down to 23 million
dollars of General funds you could do
that in an amendment and then we'd
present it to the full committee
so you're welcome to do that
thank you Mr chair I mean I guess if
they were here I would ask them
where the 25 million dollar amount came
from ask about the plan I mean those are
all sorts of specifics that we usually
inquire about
on a capital project of this nature and
I guess I would also ask the status of
the almost 10 million dollars that we
invested previously on on moving doj
over to the Granite whatever building so
sorry I know I'm a co-sponsor of this
bill but I did have a lot of questions
now that's all right it's not a problem
like you said earlier it's always good
to ask questions
so we
we can recess this to a day next week
we'll put this first on our agenda as
far as Bill hearings and then deal with
the tunnel after that but I'm not sure
the date yet without looking but if you
want to get together representative Ebel
with
the commissioner and Terry path to work
out
language that
you're happy with that would be great
we also have a facilities come
I forget so maybe there'll be more
discussion there all right great thank
you
actually at 8 30 I think
so I don't yeah
brother yes representative yes Mr chair
thank you I had one more question for
chairman Weiler
um you mentioned earlier that in the off
sessions at the city of Concord would be
using the garage would it ever be just a
question for my constituents would it
ever be open to the public to be used
for its free parking space or does that
ever happen yes I think that was part of
the if Concord had one of these street
fairs like they frequently have they
would want to use it for that and so you
know that was one of the reasons they
they'd say yes we want to be able to
have the use of it and you know we
leave the gate up or whatever whatever
the we had for that so yeah
and as a follow-up to your question one
of the things that um we heard I think
last week
was it all the parking spaces that are
taken like on Park Street and around the
state house and the lob would no longer
be occupied by legislators giving the
public more access to these buildings so
and more revenue for conquer right
well before representative McGuire has
any questions we'll recap
all right
so all right we'll uh keep an eye to the
calendar and we'll be back next week
thanks